hello hello welcome welcome today is a very special day
because it is i think almost like past the one year
anniversary but um it's like been a year since we last
played god of war and i figured it's the perfect time to
come back as the father with my milk and be like hello son i
am back now to make sure you're not still a fucking pussy uh
oh wait no he is Because we found out he was Loki.
So he's still going to be a goddamn pussy.
The day I discovered my son was a goddamn magic user.
I...
Oh, God.
Okay, I'm still sick, guys.
Back the boy.
I just remembered my revelation where I was like, no!
He's going to be the first twink!
No!
world's first twink no i raised him when she yeah so a lot
of the first of a lot of things um so yeah so i i am back to
play god dad of war oh yeah and the first furry he was the
first he was a
um he truly was a pioneer a trendsetter um he walked so they
could run
anyway um i i am still sick unfortunately um i'm at the
phase where i start coughing which is the worst part because
like as you guys remember it is a tradition where um i have
the aftermath of the i mean i still have the cold i'm still
i'm still like i'm still blowing my nose and everything but
it comes with the you know um it comes with the fact that i
i could be coughing for maybe a couple of days or it could
last two to three months who knows it's a fucking gamble so
we'll see Because last night I didn't have a lot of I didn't
have a lot of good sleep today Because I was coughing myself
awake and then I woke up with like super dry throat because
I was coughing a lot So I think I only had around like three
to four hours to sleep overall just because I kept coughing
myself awake So let's hope let's hope my gamma luck is not
that bad
but it doesn't last a couple of months because I do have to
record some stuff this month.
So I'm just like praying to God.
I'm like, please, I have to every time.
Every time I'm like, I'm setting motion some things where I
have to record something, I get sick.
It happened for like the birthday concert.
It happened for like Phantom Thief.
It happened for like voice packs.
It's like I don't know fucking know why.
I'm like, oh, I've got to record something, um, on audacity.
And then I'm like, okay, I'm going to, I have to like make
sure I have everything set up.
And then the moment I'm like, I'm ready.
I get sick.
And it's, it's, it's like every time I have that thought, it
just comes in.
My body is like, no, we must stop you physically.
I'm actually cursed.
But yes, but at least not as cursed as God of war.
My most delayed series I've ever done.
Like something always happens for God of War.
It sucks that we didn't get played the first part like two
days ago.
But at least we're playing it.
Good thing I scheduled it twice.
So at least we get to play it this week.
Anyway, before we begin, we do have something very important
to do before we begin God of War.
I do remember what happened in the last game.
Because there is a hint that, what was it?
um someone is coming uh in the second game i assume it's
like it's thor right so we're gonna be meeting thor um and
uh i don't and that's all i know uh and then we found out
that my son is actually loki and um and i was like oh no oh
no he's gonna meet a oh no he's gonna meet a horse and i
can't stop it all i can do is let watch it happen No!
Boy!
He's gonna... He's gonna meet a horse.
Anyway, um...
It's just you cannot change... That's the worst part.
As the father, I cannot change destiny.
And I think that is the worst part.
Anyway, I have a very important thing to do before.
before we uh start today's stream uh because a very
important update came out today and i gotta go shopping i
gotta go shopping right now before i forget um give me a sec
guys this very this is absolutely important yes a very
important update came out i told you guys all right here we
go So if you guys didn't know, self-park, oh wait, also
reminder, the code does refresh if you don't use it after
like a certain amount of weeks.
So remember to type dokeybird and support a creator over
here.
And then it's time to spend money on cosmetics and then not
touch the game after.
Time to window shop.
Oh my God, look at 10,000.
Oh my, I'm going to...
i'm gonna be cartman he has cartman land i have dokey land
like we're practically okay i shouldn't say that but like i
i i will my i will not get tally because i think sponge bob
is better as the side it's so funny having a sponge running
around um i don't know if i should just buy cartman and then
because i just really oh but i could have kenny and kyle and
but oh my god okay there's a lot going on oh my god wait
Master Chief is back Oh my god, look at the Joker driving
the little warthog Oh my, okay, wait, wait Oh my god, wait,
Master Chief is back Oh fuck, okay, I have to get Master
Chief, obviously I don't care about that though What else do
they have right now in the shop?
I heard like the repo guys are back I don't know, they're
back today or like another Another week Yes, also the reason
why I stream this whenever I buy stuff is so It's like it's
like a tax right off to um guys we have to game the system
it is like a business expense this is a this i'm streaming
it so it's business uh it's it's technically business
because i am streaming it damn i am a i told you remember i
got what's his name i got that danny davido character that
like it's i'm the ruthless business woman bro hey geez but
look i stream it so so technically it's a business expense
because this is my business what the fuck oh no i'm
definitely going to get a copyright guy bro i can't i keep
forgetting that like okay that like i oh it's already too
late i paid played like enough songs for it okay what else
the repo guys aren't here yet oh that's so yeah um Okay,
okay, we're gonna get the South Park bundle and then oh my
god 17 items.
What a steal guys What okay, I will save and what's this?
They're waiting a Okay, what is this one No, this is cool a
day.
Yeah, it's practically free guys Oh my god.
Oh my okay, that's pretty cool The Osimo Crowbar, the Sun,
oh my, Princess Kini's, Royal Scepter, oh my god, they have
everything.
And apparently, cred is coming out later, so I'm definitely
going to get cred, because we all need cred.
It's creepy with the chocolate.
Okay, how many?
Okay, I have zero V bucks for now.
Give me a sec.
Give me a sec, guys.
I like how, like, because, like, apparently Kazuna, I, okay,
I'm sorry about pronouncing her name wrong.
um i'm sorry i'm really bad pronunciation but she is get it
got leaked that she's getting a fortnight icon skin and
people were like freaking out because they're like oh my god
that means vtubers there's a chance for vtubers to get an
icon skin and then like the one of the famous one of the
biggest like uh twitter like fortnight leak uh twitter
accounts was like oh what other vtubers are you looking
forward to and then like he posted a picture of me in there
along with like three other people who are much more bigger
content creators than me and i was like whoa how like she
thinks she's part of the team and i'm like yay i was so
surprised i was just like what wait why am i on this list
but i'll take it yay it's like it's like that fucking mean
picture of the clown with like three like tactical um like
like army men and then there's a clown in the middle of
there and that's me i'm the clown i'm like oh i'm like yeah
i think because i'm the only one with a fortnite creator
code but i literally all i do is just window shop all i do
is literally i go on buy fortnite skins and then like and
then and then tap out that's all i do i i'm literally just a
collector i just can't help it Like, maybe, like, a game or
two.
They don't even know that.
They don't need, like, I would, I would, like, try the skins
out.
But I just, I'm just like, they're, honestly, I'm their
perfect customer.
I don't clog the servers and I'm just here to window, I'm
just here to shop.
Yeah, I'm the ideal customer.
I was being like, guys, pour it in.
I know I'm going to be Cartman.
I don't want to be Cartman.
Oh my God, wait, does he have, does he wear kicks?
oh my god guys you can make him work crocs oh my god wait
okay that's that's beautiful wait i did not know that oh
like okay wait okay he obviously has to have to give me the
toilet on the back um and then i am the perfect consumer for
them oh my god wait what does it look like when i'm on
shenron oh i can't see it i can't see karmann on shenron
guys but i can guys wait
Oh my god, you're styling right now.
Also, Cartman Land is also in Fortnite right now, which is
great.
I feel like they should have made it so that only Cartman
Skins can go into Cartman Land.
Because it would make sense unless this is like post Cartman
Land where he has to make money.
But I think it would have been...
Oh, and Canada exists too.
I mean, obviously.
Canada is real, guys.
Canada is real.
But like, they added Canada in Fortnite.
And I was like, oh my god.
I feel so represented right now No way no way I don't but
yes it's real guys Oh my god Carmen was SpongeBob oh guys
also fun fact I saw this on Twitter and I was like oh my god
wait that's so true But here's a little fun fact for you
guys Like Yagami and SpongeBob SquarePants share the same
outfit Oh yeah, I should buy, I forgot.
Just so, thanks for reminding me.
I need to buy Master Chief.
Wait, can Master Chief wear Crocs?
Okay, give me a sec.
I gotta, I gotta buy this.
I gotta buy this real quick.
Well, I need to know.
Stop.
Give me a sec, guys.
I need to know.
Can Master Chief, can, can Master Chief wear Crocs?
Guys, did you know when you buy V-Bucks, there's also a
creator code and I've not been using that.
Fun fact.
When you buy Veefucks, you can also use my creator code and
I just found out about it after I don't know how much money
I've spent.
Okay.
Bite size.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Another year, another birthday.
I get to celebrate with Doki.
And the dragons.
Can I get birthdays on Doki?
Also, your good smile bunny honey.
Plus, you finally arrived.
Yeah, I'm glad it finally arrived and happy birthday to you
bite size happy birthday to you Happy birthday to you happy
birthday dear bite size happy birthday to you Yeah, happy
I'm so happy that your stuff arrived too.
All right All right, here you go.
I got it.
We got to try it.
We got to see.
Oh my god, we gotta see oh my
god worth it oh my okay wait wait i gotta see if he wears
crap if he can wear my nike shoes oh my god master chief you
are you're truly uh you're truly styling right now You are
dripped up right now with Yo's Kicks, Master Chi.
Okay, make him dance.
Oh, you're so right.
You're for...
Okay, wait.
But with what, though?
With the Air...
Oh, wait.
What does he look like with Air Jordans?
Oh, my God.
Okay, yeah.
There we go.
Oh, but the Nike shoes go hard, though.
Or with the Squidward...
Squidward Crocs.
Okay, wait.
No, I think...
Okay, we gotta give him Air Jordans.
Jordans and then wait is there any new shoes okay this is
important battle ready Akhan start your engines where are
the shoes where are the shoes kick stereo see results any oh
my god the pickle stomper okay any new air Jordans there's
air Jordans oh my god it's the messy oh my god wait try it
on oh my god now he's bawling um oh there's like clothes oh
wait this is cool i don't collect shoes but like this is
cool this is cheaper oh there's the adidas all right okay
okay okay wait okay i gotta focus all right we gotta make
him dance oh wait the white is like hard to see okay i'll
give him the nike shoes you can see the nike shoes better
there we go all right what dance do i have okay i'm sorry i
please don't unsubscribe
yeah let's go master chief let's go
no matter what this is still better than the live action
halo shows you're welcome he's go my boy he's balling guys
please i i'm like on a war Guys, I swear to God.
Eris, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Doki.
I always forget to message you on my birthday, but not this
time.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
Oh my God, wait.
Wait, here.
I'll still dance for you for your birthday.
Give me a sec.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Eris.
Oh my god, he's so C-Slay right now.
He's, I gotta believe it.
All right, all right.
All right, now that I've made my very important purchase
today, um, oh my god, now that I made my very important
purchase, now we can, now that the main game is over, I
guess we can play, I guess we can start our side quest right
now.
Um, did I tell you guys I got the 6-7 E-Mode?
on Overwatch recently, like on Soldier 76.
I think that is like perfect marketing right there,
honestly.
So like the fact that Soldier 76 was technically born during
the time, like he basically grew up, he's Gen Alpha.
He's literally Gen Alpha slash Zumer.
And he grew up with six, seven.
and then he named himself soldier 76 it was perfect whoever
whoever whoever the dev was that came up with the concept
concept of soldier 76 he could see the future he was a
prophet he truly the guy who devout who create con like
conceptualized soldier 76 knew what was going to happen yeah
it's lower accurate it's actually lower accurate people were
like would never do that but he was actually he was
literally a gen gen alpha slash zoomer wait is it booting up
why the fuck where's god of war i did not sorry i should oh
there it is new controller firmware ignore please all right
i'm trying to boot up guys don't worry it's running it's
synchronizing cloud it says it's running now it's it says
it's running oh oh the browser popped up oh progress is
being made we're starting our side quest now
oh okay uh we do not need a skip all right oh oh yeah i
bought the okay i'm so fucking stupid.
I bought the game the day after the Steam sale because I
forgot to buy Ragnar Ragnar.
I was like, oh, it's alright, I have the game already.
And then I, like, literally the day after the Steam sale, I
was like, wait, what is this said?
Why can't I find the copy of the game?
And it was January 6th when I discovered it.
Um, and then I paid $80.
Uh, boy, got a boy.
The thing is, I um let's see common settings all right the
worst part is that i bought i like bought in advance all the
other games that was going to be playing the next two weeks
but for some but they were all like super cheap like you
know ten dollars fifteen dollars and of course the one game
the most expensive triple a title is the one that i forgot
to buy is speech size ui i don't know i feel blind I'm just
gonna put large actually that's fine defaults fine lock on
camera classic auto target unlocks my target dies or aiming
target make break also like because I've been blowing my
nose a lot which fucking sucks when it picks up health and
race rage stones when need I'm just gonna do essentials
picks up how loot drops went out of combat picks up full
okay I'm just gonna do essentials and then I'll in case i
need help uh actually no because then it if i don't need it
and then i'll waste the pickup yeah never mind uh no i feel
like because like sometimes you save the health and stuff so
like if you need like you know uh you know like uh you want
to save it for like another fight and or something and then
i don't want to pick it up if that happens allows for
additional traversal includes vaulting uh mantling jumping
gaps and includes vaulting climbs i like i'll do auto for
that it might be easier uh uh jumping gaps or okay i feel
yeah i'm gonna do auto for that oh whoops i'll do auto for
that should be good all right uh motion reduction with
motion reduce increases stability making play movement a
smooth and steady cinematic smoothing removes quick
movements and sharp jarring enables oh we can just get rid
of motion blur red later uh you're playing husband sim a
demo I feel like I'm playing father simulator more uh our
audio should be good yeah also sound guy are you around oh
there he goes sorry me also yeah like i said i was blowing
my i've been blowing my nose a lot so my ears have been like
what's the word popped a lot and not great especially right
now it's like clogged um okay no like this game came out a
while ago already oh i'm still compiling shaders oh we
should get a recap for sure all right aim assist oh my god
what's classic plus points to the aim reticle from anywhere
on screen points to closest target already relative point
okay okay puzzle aim assist from nearby when aiming puzzle
timing default lock in camera i'm so tempted guys i'm so
tempted to go classic plus i guys i'm not very good with
controller uh All right, auto pickup, minigame, tutorial
mode, pause on focus loss, reduced puzzle hit, weapon
sheafing, HUD.
Okay, none of these I need to worry about.
Okay, graphics and camera.
All right, this is what, oh yeah, that 500 hertz.
Yeah, that's right.
Okay, let's just in case so my PC doesn't explode because I
have no idea how far this goes oh just 144 okay that's fine
latency frame gen quality medium i mean i'm fine maybe high
can't be that bad how about ultra okay let's go high i
shouldn't test my look i shouldn't all right let's grab the
motion blur down here um
camera shake i'm not a does not okay yeah okay does not
affect synonym sudden this usually occurs okay yeah we don't
okay ambient okay we we don't need camera shake right guys
like that's not gonna ruin your immersion because I
personally I I personally fucking hate camera shake so I'm I
hope that that doesn't ruin your immersion because I'm not a
fan of that shit all right
it's yeah i i don't think that i personally do not think
okay uh that camera shake matters let's give them color just
because wait it doesn't give them different no okay never
mind i thought like each speaker would have a different okay
wait water freezes i would like to know what's happening all
right let's have let's have big guys yeah that's fine you
must prepare okay wait how big is that extra okay oh that's
fine large is fine and caption blur okay i don't think we
need do you guys see this without do you guys need i don't
think you need the subtitle and caption blur honestly i
think it's fine don't break my immersion in cam bit thinking
with a super chat thinking like i i don't know let's see
it's fine i can't read anyway
all right uh and that's good text in color oh wait what can
he what language oh united oh text language okay wait french
espagnol portuguese italian german polish wait do they have
they're they're they're north gods right wait they don't
even have like how am i gonna be immersed if they don't
speak the the scandinavian languages how can i be
this this lacks my immersion all right let's see okay i
think that's good i think that's everything that we should
be good to go now all right let's fucking do this god okay
let's watch a recap okay let's watch a recap and then let's
fucking do this just in case okay i remember that we had to
climb all the way up there the gods of these realms don't
take kindly to outsiders trust me that sound guy if you're
ready you a balance.
Because I'm ready.
There's only one person alive who can get you, but you need
to go.
First, you need to cut off my head.
I remember that.
I forgot his name, though.
Oh, there's my pet snake.
I know.
The god of Warstream is finally real.
I chose to live as a man.
But the truth is, I was born a god.
Oh, oh yeah, Mimmer!
Mimmer!
Me, me, me, me, me, me.
No, damn, my boy.
My boy, he became a mad.
No, I should be like, yeah, my boy became a mad dude.
I don't remember this.
Oh yeah, and then he tried to, oh shit.
Wait, he tried to kill his mom.
My dear sweet boy.
Look, she was a giant.
I'm a giant.
I guess there's just one thing I don't understand.
The Giants called me, Loki?
That's when I knew.
I see the future of my boy.
I see the future of my boy, and I can't stop it.
I can't stop the outcome.
That's the worst part.
I can't stop it.
I...
That's so...
All right.
is sound guy alive because I didn't hear him say anything
and that's what I'm worried about is sound guy alive right
now what's this
alright hello sound guy what did you think about the audio
before we go in because we can do this right now with the
recap I think recap was a good balance
here is the audio settings for you we just get it off right
off the bat recap was very low okay i upped it up a lot more
now all right let's go in new game give me a story give me
grace give me balance all right we could do balance yeah we
could do balance i don't know it's not it's like a combat
game and not really fps so i i can't tell
God of war.
That guy knows what's up.
Yeah, I'm definitely going to get the blur off.
I didn't think we actually need the blur or the subtitles.
Just keep throwing your axe.
Yeah, but then remember a lot of people got mad at me for
just using my axe.
They're like, Kratos has like a million combos, and yet all
you're doing is throwing your axe, and I'm like, axe go,
I think I rage baited too many people.
I literally made a fighting game of an FPS.
Where's my son?
Where did you...
Oh, no.
Boy, come back here!
Do not interact with the wildlife!
No!
Oh, God, it's dead.
Thank God.
It's dead.
Oh my god, he hit puberty!
He was just hunting, guys.
Boy was just hunting.
He has yet to discover his furry side.
Like, my home?
This home is getting worse.
Are we going back to our gods?
Or still in the Norse realm?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I bet he has...
I bet he grew his first armpit hair, guys.
He's growing up so fast.
He's in puberty.
He's growing hair now.
That's not just on his head.
Game is still real low.
Okay, don't worry.
I'm just gonna head out and it's gonna transition to the
game.
Naturally.
Right?
Oh my god, no, not the wolves.
Oh my god.
No, that's that's the gateway drug that No, boy stay away
from the wolves.
It's the gateway drug Stay away
Stop Inside of you there are two wolves
Oh?
Man, my 59 is doing fucking work right now.
Thank God I got rammed before the fucking market exploded.
Oh, shit!
Okay, that scared me.
Alright, okay, now, alright, now we can...
Alright, sound gap.
I'm raising the volume up again.
and yeah and then also i have i did not i did not like the
uh where is it where the fuck is audio okay there you go i
did not like the blur the blur was too much for sure uh wait
yeah i'm taking the blur off yeah that that was like wolf's
jump scare right there yeah uh what else does the subtitle
need changing or anything or is it five the subtitle size
was huge all right we'll take it down a little we'll do a
default all right all right here we go let's go let's go my
wolves let's go yeah let's go it's bonto time wait your son
okay wait how accurate is his lord is it is it fennier his
son no no it already happened boy i'm not giving up on it
don't work don't boy what did i tell you the walls are the
gateway late it happened in between the games hello oh Freya
are we enemies now oh it's because she bro I saved the world
Freya get out of here your son was evil okay Her son was
evil.
I literally saved the world.
She wouldn't give up that easy.
She never does.
Stay alert.
All right.
Okay, now she's mad at me.
I mean, to be fair, the gods did kill like his entire
family.
And then he also sort of killed all the gods.
So like, you know, he should be able to relate.
What am I supposed to do for that?
What is this icon?
What is this circular?
Okay, circle.
Oh, that's circle.
The circular thing is circle.
Okay, I...
I just I okay look intuition wise I should have known that I
what is the circular icon what could it be I guys I do have
an excuse I am like really sick right now I stop get out of
here oh shit oh my god oh my god I didn't know you cannot
buttons oh okay all right she just broke my neck that's not
okay i was spamming l1 i didn't realize that you can't you
don't do that all right all right l1 r1 l1 all right here we
go where do we go okay here it's okay we gotta see a cool
neck crack though let's learn basic shapes what is this
shape oh shit oh wouldn't it be better if she kills my son
so then it's like an eye for an eye or i should not give her
ideas all right yeah
like because then it's like my son is such a easy target
compared to me.
Like, I mean, like you can snap him.
He's a fucking twig.
Like, I actually fight back.
Yeah, we did it.
We made it.
Let us go home.
It's Becky.
It's Fana.
yeah my two pet doggos well my two grandsons but like they
could be both see look at that she can't even fucking kill
her yeah there's no letting that go
yeah all right here we go oh yeah balder really did bring on
fumble winter never stopped snowing after that day oh oh
yeah it's ever gonna get better there's no summer no more
it's just an eternal winter seasonal depression forever oh
yeah we should adjust the audio um what was it music down by
one sound effects down by three dialogue all right let's why
the fuck forgot my controller does sounds now oh i'm using
my custom the dokeybird controller right now
But...
Because it's a PlayStation game.
Terminator, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What's that circular thing?
Is this a reason?
So do you know how funny for an AI?
Look, it's because the circle was white and not red, okay?
I got it.
I see red circle and I'm like, oh, circle.
But I see white circle and I'm like, what is that shape?
Is that a square?
I've been trained Since the PlayStation 1 To associate red
circle With circle I will get the deer
Is that a square?
What is that What is that circular symbol On my controller?
Alright Alright Wait, I don't even have sons?
They're both daughters?
Uh, granddaughters?
Who will continue the bloodline, boy?
You can't even get that, right?
Boy!
Our two grandkids, my two grandkids aren't even grandsons.
No one can continue the bloodline now.
I have to accept it.
Like, what can I do?
You started the fist phase.
guess I explore I go up I assume the the light is my yellow
yeah my yellow tape always says hello Petraeus Ben rear
where oh oh there's my house
hello hello my grandson no I
missed you too still hungry no Oh, I just met him and now...
Why aren't you eating?
I just met you.
You're my grandson.
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Andreas, your hand draws near.
You must prepare yourself.
How do I save him?
Where's the quick time event to save him?
he's still eating he wants to live he's dying oh this
is why this is also why i'm not i'm not playing the dog game
you're a good boy that every other vtubers playing right now
i i would actually cry like i'm so sad right now fast and
strong no but you can rest now i'll be okay someone take him
to the vet where's the door spent you have to let go no no
no no no no no no no
Sofna.
Sofna?
No.
What happened to him?
Oh
no, it's raining.
What a bad day for rain.
Come.
We train.
What?
what his son died no it's the middle of the night he got
sick night does not stop our enemies why what for drinking
is all we ever do ever it's not enough we can't hide forever
not hide oh my god bro that's not healthy kratos we cannot
deal with grief by just punching things bro we need therapy
time is running out the prophecy say fimbal winter leads to
ragnarok war is coming whatever loki's supposed to be doing
he's supposed to be doing it now okay um oh that's awkward
hiding in these woods oh that's awkward yeah where the fuck
is loki Yeah, this fucking Loki guy, what the fuck is he
doing?
I know, right, Arteus?
Fuck that guy.
And if those answers lead to war with Asgard.
Maybe that's what Mother wanted.
You do not know what Mother wanted.
Looks like we never will.
Does he know?
If only we knew where Loki is.
Oh, yeah, I'll up the voices a little bit more.
I just want to...
Oh, shit.
Oh, sorry.
This was why I didn't want to up it yet.
But I'll...
Look.
I have a moment alone with Fenrir before I bury him.
Oh.
I'm so sad.
Are we going to tell the other kids?
Like, the other...
other kids you know that the other dogs did it's okay all
dogs go to heaven i don't know in nor if they do in norse
mythology but like i assume they also go to vahala all dogs
go to vahala right right
well i don't recognize that dull expression anywhere what
went wrong
he was in the fight the dog was in the fight with his own
body that's the fight his blood cells were these white blood
cells were fighting technically it
was an old age it was sick
what the fuck who the fuck is it what the fuck that's creepy
it was like what lady touched me
my inner demons my sleep paralysis demon
Freya.
Oh, is she invading my dreams?
Oh my god, it's like, woman!
Are you joining me?
What the fuck am I having dreams, like, hot, sexy dreams
about the woman that's trying to kill me?
Oh, it's Faye, not Freya.
Sorry, I'm very bad at you.
Oh, it's the giant.
It's the giant woman.
The emir himself sits atop your shoulders.
Okay.
She's your aunt.
Wait, she's not as...
Wait.
She's not a giant.
Wait, did she shrink her?
Oh, yeah, I forgot the Norse giants can shrink themselves.
No, no, come on.
That's not fun.
Come on.
Kratos is freaky.
Am I to decipher your grunting?
Tell me your thoughts.
We hunt a predator.
A wolf.
Yes.
Predators kill.
It is the natural order of things.
Your words are misguided.
Oh, for this one, they don't know how to turn big.
for the in-the-game.
Because usually in Norse mythology...
Oh, hey.
We want to help.
Oh, is this Fenyer?
Oh!
Don't!
Come on.
Like, in the regular Norse mythology, the giants can grow
big or small.
I know, like, Loki was abandoned because he was too small.
Like, in the original.
It was not our concern.
Now it is.
Oh.
doesn't have to reach our doorstep for it to be our
responsibility if we have the power to limit the harm it
could cause we should act who are we to hide and do nothing
we are not hiding
oh that's a marvel rival sort okay i like mixed them up they
blur together for me now sometimes miss mix up the mark
because i was like i would read about low Loki in rivals,
sorry, in Marvel lore, and I would read about regular Loki
lore, and then it all blurted it together.
I cannot differentiate between Marvel Norse mythology and
regular Norse mythology now.
I was like, what is that?
Is that square?
I... Which
one is the weird one?
Obviously, the OG one.
The fact that, like, his dad, after he gave...
birth to a horse his dad was like this is my horse now
that's all right is yeah odin was like all right i shall now
use your son as my as my horse it hovered toward and
automatically one or press oh wait oh the ledge i thought i
was climbing the log this way very
Odin is not his dad, but yes, look, that's why I'm saying it
blurred together for me.
It mixed together.
Because when I was growing up, I love reading about
different mythologies from around the world.
So I was, like, super into that.
Oh.
Where did you grab the yellow paint?
And then, like, and then I read about, like, the Marvel
lore, like, Marvel mythologies and stuff, and then it
blurred together.
Where's Atreus?
Hence my bellowing.
There's yellow paint on his head.
We can climb it now and support it.
It cannot be far.
All right.
What if they wanted to warn me?
Where's the dog?
Hey, I want to go back.
Journal unlocked.
Oh, okay.
Is this?
No?
We're unlocking the journal.
Oh, it's the review objectives.
I'm gonna go back.
That's most likely where he did the burying.
Where's the dog?
Far's dwindling now.
Hello.
Where else could he have gone from here?
Your brother is dead.
I'm sorry.
Also, I upped the volume a bit more.
Sound guy.
Let me know if it's better.
Yeah, I've had a feeling.
Bam.
You seem troubled in your sleep.
Even for you.
nightmares i dream of the past almost every night oh that's
not good we should take melatonin in greece no it feels like
phase what is he trying to do you don't mean to say you're
talking to ghosts again brother no but it is something more
than memory
okay he's trying to send me a message she gave me yellow
paint what does it mean the track stop And we're not alone.
Oh, shit.
All right, it's fine.
Boom.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
I juggle you.
Boom.
Get juggled.
That's right.
Oh, my God.
I fucking cut this man in half.
Old X.
Okay.
All right.
That's actually pretty good.
know oh shit wait oh my god i i got confused between xbox
controller and playstation i was pressing i was i was
pressing the square button instead for evade because i
forgot how i hate i hate that i hate that they're both they
put the symbols on different shapes double tap while moving
to roll okay that's good to know behind you brother don't
worry okay the shield didn't work but Don't worry!
Yeah, I was pressing square.
Wait, what?
What's this?
Oh, shit!
That's right!
Split you in half!
Get juggles!
Oh, shit.
You should not be this close.
Yeah, what are they doing here?
There's a tree up ahead, yeah?
Chop, chop!
Bam!
Whoa, oh, never mind.
I thought I was...
that strong, I guess.
Okay, like, cutting it in half would have also worked, too.
Oh, yeah, nice.
Well, you were right.
The state is broken.
Explains our trespassers.
What happened here?
Oh, wait.
Where did they break it?
Was it on...
Oh, my God.
What did they do to the poor bear?
Hello?
Are you okay?
Do you need help?
The bear.
Mold.
By what?
Do you think it's dead?
Oh, shit.
larger bear the fight destroyed the tree oh i between the
savage beasts and marauding radars he may have sought
shelter follow the trail oh no that's the worst part when
you die from a bigger version of you left or right right
here okay that's where the blood stain is the left side is
the fun side never mind it goes the same way which means
this might Oh, never mind.
My gaming intuition led me to nothing.
All right, let's see.
Oh, yeah, nice.
I knew there was something here.
The boy is alone with an animal.
Yay!
I'm glad I still punched chess.
Wait, can I?
All right.
Is there a Doki and Doki verse that's just bigger than the
rest?
Thank you for the super chat, Alan.
you think oh my god this is it it's fbs tap oh where's my
axe hi there you go any idea what could have made the lad
wonder off we argued he accuses me of hiding from odin yeah
only sensible to accuse me of being a pussy how dare he that
is why atreus must learn to survive on his own that I'm a
goddamn pussy.
Guess because the giants had you dead on some wall full of
otherwise accurate predictions.
I do not believe in prophecies.
Well...
I knew it.
I was like, I see blood here, which means...
Wait.
Maybe?
We can't get across there from here.
Okay.
Alright, fine.
I don't know, I just thought it would work somehow.
What the fuck?
Why are so many entrances for no reason?
reason let's find him all right yoink he's dead so it's not
robbing i'm just making sure nothing is wasted okay nice
like remember lat when remember when doki didn't believe in
prophecies and how well did that turn out for her all right
there we go surely surely our loki is down here right I'm
skeptical by nature, though we have seen things that defy
explanation.
So, speaking as the smartest man alive, I have no bloody
idea.
But, well, to frost up the axe, powering up the necks.
Oh, FPS time.
Whoa!
Yeah!
Look, okay, I'll start fighting when they get closer to me.
But, look, I'm...
They're not close.
see look at that look at that when they get closer then i'll
use my other attacks but because they have yet to reach me
then i have justification to use it when you want me to run
up to them oh shit oh shit okay okay now see look at that
see they got closer look okay it does the same amount of
damage when I shoot my axe.
Like, come on.
I feel like at that point, if I am closer, I should be able
to do more damage with my melee.
That's my FPS VTuber.
All I'm saying is that why?
Okay, wait.
Let's see.
Alright, see, look.
Boom!
What the fuck?
That's right.
Get shot!
That's fine.
There we go.
Yeah, switching to your axes faster than reloading to
your...
Oh wait, that's true.
Hey guys, like that combo?
I don't even know what I did.
Just in case.
I'm pre-firing.
What did I do there?
Like...
Wait, is he...
Oh shit!
There we go.
Where's the other guy?
Oh there he is.
Oh shit!
Okay there we go.
That's fucking right!
BAM!
Draw my combos!
Guys, that's funny that you mentioned, Barry.
That's so funny.
I know what you're thinking, brother.
But Atreus can handle himself.
Don't worry, he's a man now.
So he keeps telling me.
I believe in him.
His voice dropped.
His balls literally dropped.
Alright.
Yeah, it's okay.
They're raiders.
So, like, they're grazed me nothing to me.
So technically, I'm justified to Since they're raiders, I'm
justified to rave the graves.
I'm sure we can find a quiet way in.
Wild way.
What's that?
I don't know what quiet is.
Oh, you can do that.
Yeah, free stuff.
We rather fight a dokey-sized bird or a 50-bird-sized dokey.
Thank you for the super chat, Turner.
Thank you, thank you.
He's the leaders you rescued the wolves from.
They have not been here long.
You think they'll notice?
Now we're fired.
Loot is loot.
Alright.
Death from above.
Oh, shit.
Wait, that's cool.
What?
Oh.
Okay, there you go.
Second time's the charge.
He didn't notice.
He didn't notice my war cry.
Thank God.
thank i'm glad i'm glad they didn't hear my war cry thank
god it worked what oh there it is
watch this oh wait okay myself war cry that's right it's
okay he was actually deaf thank god thank god that guy was
deaf and my All right.
Okay, let's grab his stuff.
Yoink.
Oh, Jakarta.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I mean, okay, I'm greedy.
I don't care.
I'm full HP if I'll still take it.
Boy, is there anything else I can destroy here?
Might be extra loot.
This is what Zelda taught me.
I've never played a Zelda game in my life.
But I know that we always have to smash.
everything you see.
Now that's what we call what we all been waiting for.
FPS gamer, dogeeper, don't change.
It's what Dragon's One.
Between Batman and God War, we love projectiles.
Thank you for the super chat, Takata.
Thank you.
Where is he?
Where?
I hear noises.
Oh, there they are.
It's okay.
all right when they get closer you guys know what's gonna
happen there we go
all right it's fine oh what the oh my god i forgot about the
file girl where is she oh there she is oh wait what there we
go that's right i could do that too that's right
That's fucking right.
That's why you don't fully invest in archery.
In range.
You gotta diversify.
Yeah, but art one is fast.
You gotta learn to do both.
I get over there.
Oh, there.
That's how.
Yay!
Grave-robbing, my favorite part of this game.
It's okay.
I killed everyone around me, so is it truly grave-robbing if
no one can see?
Boom!
That's right.
Why are you hitting yourself?
Okay, I can do the sprint thing, but I don't need to.
Bad.
but why the fuck are you not climbing is there someone i'm
missing oh oh whoops oh look i couldn't i didn't know they
were they were just these ladies were just standing there i
guess they were waiting for their turn are you here how is
that supposed i was so confused i was like why is the
benefits let's find a way perhaps a cheus came here seeking
shelter saw the raiders and the bear came battling after
impressive rampage i'll give it that you think the bear was
chasing atreus well just as likely the bear was hurt and
atreus was chasing it to help how does he help chasing it oh
i guess to eat the dog i guess it's like free food all right
but but the sound is okay now right guys yeah kratos just
likes to make the ladies wait for their turn so polite what
Oh my god, the bigger bear!
Well, it's not even like a special bear.
The bear's just bigger.
Oh shit, a circle, circle, a square button.
Oh my god, it's okay.
Oh my god, it's worn!
Okay.
Oh my god.
Isn't that like... Oh shit, I did not mean to do that.
Wait, isn't that like...
PewDiePie's son's name?
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Bro, I'm trying to dodge.
Okay, here we go.
Bro, this bear.
Oh, my God.
Okay, this is fine.
Okay, that's where I have to pair.
it bro what the
holy shit this fucking bear is crazy no wonder the other
bear fucking got fucked up okay smack his ass though oh my
god oh okay i'm trying to figure out if i can parry this but
i don't know how oh my god he reacts so fast i don't know
what the timing is okay there was a green here give me a sec
going
I feel it.
Jesus Christ.
Bro!
Get the fuck off me!
Okay.
Jesus.
I'm not doing so well.
Okay.
Smack the ass.
Back out.
No!
I did it!
I backed out though!
He's so fast!
wait oh my god it's scripted it's so it's scripted a fucking
course a fucking course I was never that's right I'm fucking
beating up the goddamn bear a fucking course that shit I was
like bro do you see the size of that goddamn bear like how
in the fuck was I supposed to kill that guy I fucking do it
it's always scripted.
Oh my god!
My god!
Like, I was like, bro!
Run up!
This is my first boss!
Oh my god, I'm gonna get my Oscars.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, there you go.
Oh my god.
Bro, I...
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
Okay, I got the...
Okay.
I... Oh my...
It's fine.
I'm just gonna start blocking.
Jesus.
Jesus Christ.
Oh.
Okay.
That's fine.
Okay, it's fine.
Oh, it's no longer five!
It's no longer five!
Oh, God.
He's beating me the fuck up, guys.
I swear to God.
Slap!
Slap the bear!
Oh, God.
A fucking course.
No!
Woo!
I tried.
I tried to get the fucking greed.
Ah!
Okay, I'm locked in.
now that i know oh my god thank god free hits gotta beat up
the bear all right i'm slowly figuring it out it's okay
there you go oh nice nice what are you fucking getting
he's all things
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
There we go.
That's five.
I figured it out.
I figured out how to do it.
There we go.
I told you.
Oh my god.
What?
Okay.
That's fucking bullshit.
I parried like twice there.
Get out of here.
I told you I locked in.
I'm like an AI.
I learned.
I learned from it.
I'm literally AI.
There you go.
Snap that neck!
That's right!
What the fuck?
Wait.
Oh, Artyus?
Wait, Artyus?
What?
What happened?
Boy?
Oh my god, is this what puberty is?
Like men?
Oh shit, oh shit.
Don't you hate it when you started puberty and just turned
into a giant fucking bear?
I prayed Fenrir.
And then I'm not sure.
I was so sad.
Oh, his first, first suit.
And then I was angry
and scared.
And I remember running.
Sandy, thank you.
Sandy, Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Charging and I charged back.
Oh.
That had to be a dream.
Oh, I beat up my own son.
Don't kill our child protective surfaces.
I- I didn't know I could do that.
Oh.
You did not do anything.
Wasn't you.
They overcame you.
Well, puberty is hard, man.
That's why we must not abandon your training.
You will be dangerous without discipline to control.
show them you've already taught me discipline i need more
than that i need answers answers you don't have answers only
your mother had that's how she withheld yeah it's your
mother's fault she just had to die someone that could give
us answers about the giants and who loki's supposed to be so
selfish wouldn't it help to understand what i'm becoming
betrayers listen to
Yeah, don't blame me.
Blame your dead mom.
Inaction is also a risk.
You taught me that.
Stop thinking like a father for a moment and start thinking
like a general.
No!
I'm not only...
Well, they're not my only child, but like, the other ones
are dead.
But I'm the only one that's alive.
Yeah, I continue the bloodline.
Oh my god, wait.
How did I...
Helpful after a fight if Kratos is created.
hurt okay that's good to know all right chop chop oh now i
chopped a tree oh
i'll chop again oh should be fine now this way control
though thank you for the super chat thank you thank you no
that's not a horse guys yeah are we he hasn't met a horse
yet we need to repair the protection stave and get home
another protection stave you did so you're blaming me i mean
i'm i'm just stating the fat oh my god he's a teenager bro
that's the scale oh my gosh i was a teenager and now this is
what i'm worried about kids because teenagers are like the
worst kind to like the worst phase of a child
New square to command a can't come at come at because I knew
I was a shitty teenager
Use command a command and attack arrow deals extra damage to
oh wait that's what square is for there you go oh wait I
could do that too watch this okay you do that and then I do
this and then I week okay and then my turn okay boom there
you go and then oh wait he's dead dead all right nice so lad
besides your gift of language and healing creatures thoughts
are there any other new magical abilities to report not
really what to finrier what about him when he died you cast
a spell Oh, it's the blue light.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Hmm.
Check your fumble winter, perhaps.
Seen my share.
Like I was like, don't worry.
I was a good teenager, but only in the 20s where my
rebellious phase started.
I think that's worse because when you're at 20, then you're
legally allowed to drink and also like drink and also drive,
but not, don't do that at the same time, obviously.
Don't drink and drive.
But I think that's worse because you're more of an adult
having your rebellious phase.
So you are a slow cooker.
You are a slow burn.
What a freak.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What if the kid started?
Oh, my God.
You're like, boy, stop this six, seven at once, boy.
That or any prey you might have been dragging, I suppose.
Not sure that makes me feel any better.
All right.
We go home now.
artists.
Low-key.
I'm just gonna call it a low-key.
Less syllables.
This one.
He's doing the magic.
Oh.
What's that?
No!
You killed the mom!
Why are there so many dead animals in this game?
consequences oh what what can we do oh nothing we should
take them no no we should take them we should adopt them
Fritos we should adopt them they're babies no go back go
back
why did they run where did they go oh i'm allowed to dump
wolves but not bears okay wolves are not domesticated you
can't use that excuse on me like it's so cool we can have
pet bears oh you're so worthless how could you why did you
listen this that's so mess up i can't believe it i cannot
pet bears
they're friendship they're definitely friendship
oh i'm so mad at my boy i can't believe it they were so
friendship She!
Okay.
Oh shit.
Stupid boy.
Fucking now listens to his dad.
Did not listen to his dad throughout it and then now was
like, you're right.
You're right.
Let nature take his course.
It's like after everything.
I should be allowed to adopt a bear it's been like this all
night he must have been inside the state when I fixed it
brother bear I let you down pat your ass to the US for
chatting thank you apparel the US for chatting thank you
realm slide okay but how could things be any worse than here
well why are we not mad at crados bro his entire like it's
over for him like no amount of therapy can save crados but
the boy is still malleable like he's still young we can
still fix him you can't fix crados anymore but we can still
fix him hey spana there's literally brother bear good brave
girl that's right He's good with them.
No surprise, really.
Yeah, like he's good with animals!
We could have fucking...
You could have more siblings!
Becky, you okay?
Just a little thunder.
See, look at him!
He's so good with animals!
Oh, it's the god of thunder.
He's here.
That's why it's thundering.
Atreus!
It's bedtime.
It's past your bedtime boy.
As evenings go, that was entirely too eventful.
Though I admit it was a bit like old times there.
For a moment.
The three of us navigating some hitherto unhappened upon
patch of forest.
Been a while since you've joined us.
If that's what you mean.
Well, just tired, I suppose.
You've seen one deer hunt, you've seen them all.
How can you feel tired when you never sleep?
lad.
You'll see when you're all done.
There's bedtime.
Come.
Oh, wait.
We share a bed?
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, that's awkward.
We don't have two separate beds?
What happened to personal space?
Things are always brighter than the morning.
Oh, okay.
We do have separate beds.
Okay, thank God.
I saw two pillows and I got a little worried.
Alright, I did not see the third bed.
I was like, there's two pillows here.
Oh, I guess the other pillow is for my dead wife.
So I can't...
I told you, I don't move on.
Oh, Tor's coming.
Here's Thor!
Here's the big boy.
Before time, slap, slap that bully from my belly.
I have meat.
You would not find me good company.
Oh, I'm sure we'll find lots to talk about.
Oh my god, you're right.
He's a bear.
Yeah, I killed your brother.
Wait, he has meat.
him in.
Medi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, Balder is his son?
Oh, no.
Oh, wait.
Oh, the other two.
Oh, yeah.
I forgot about those two sons.
No, Balder is his brother.
How's that?
Yeah, I forgot about the other two guys.
They were so irrelevant.
Sorry, sons nearly like were so irrelevant that i've already
forgot about them until now oh my god odin's here the
raven's here
where's my axe yours might be thick but mine's longer i'm
sorry i had to i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry the intrusive
thoughts one
yay mead
no i think you the super chat thank you thank you go ahead
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you it was
implied you know this that's what they were thinking why are
you here that's a waste of good need
just oh there's papa i was like i know father I shall ask
him.
You seem like a calm and reasonable person.
Calm and reasonable person.
If the moment calls for...
I never had me before.
I know it's just alcohol.
I'd say the moment calls for calm.
It's okay.
You can make more suns, Thor.
Yeah, he's talking to the wrong person.
if he wants calm and reasonable.
Oh, oh, Papa!
There's his dad.
Oh my God, he has his dad to fight.
Like, bro, he brought his dad?
He's such a fucking pussy.
You have to bring your dad to the war to the fight.
The all-father.
But I think we all have a better idea of who we're dealing
with.
Now, what you did to his boys?
Self-defense.
True.
And let's be honest, they were kind of...
I know!
You raised up some spoiled brats.
He had value.
He was...
Dad counsel.
My closer.
Yeah, his mind was gone, sure.
But he had his uses, and now he's gone because of you.
Follow me.
Why is Odin talk like a fucking mafia boss?
Kabish, kabish.
Like, I feel like he's, like, in the wrong fucking region.
You're no fun anymore.
What do you want?
Yeah, he's talking like he's from the mob.
How about peace?
How does peace strike the esteemed retired God of war?
kill each other how about you stay home kick up your feet
seek no quarrel with me and i'll have none with you i do
find it funny that that one has to stop his search for tear
oh boy what did i tell you about starting quests without me
to stop it tears old ways are dead he is dead you understand
he's just missing the italian hands and then that's it then
we're square shit i'll even sweeten the deal i'll let you
keep the prisoner that i know you stole that's right i know
you're in here somewhere your silver tongue little i mean
why should we believe on what have you what have your
promises ever been what i love how like my old partner in
crime i love how like odin if he tells you snow is american
slash italian accent what kind of wisdom and then thor his
son is like scottish see that we all want the same thing all
right here's a deal i know you can trust i'll settle your
debt with odin soprano keep freya off your back
Wait, is this...
He had, like, a slight Scottish accent a little.
Is he American accent, too?
To be fair, he did not say a lot of words.
Capiche?
Oh!
Ah!
No.
I guess the battle then.
No more peace.
All right.
About time.
Oh god, mi amor!
I've been waiting for this.
You're not from here.
We got a tradition called blood payments.
It means I get a piece of you for what you took from my
family.
You'll pick it up.
Oh shit!
Thanks for explaining, I guess.
I got a little confused.
Oh, God.
Wait, where's my axe?
Wait, I don't have an axe?
Oh, God.
I know I should.
What?
I don't care.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
He almost grabbed me.
All right.
I blocked.
I need to figure out the timing for the fucking yellow.
Because I know that that would be very helpful.
Oh, nice!
That's red!
Bam!
You know my task?
The ghost of Sparta thing.
Yeah.
Am I calling it?
Where is my axe?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah!
That's fucking right.
Now we got us a fight.
What?
I was hoping to see your blade.
Okay, I have to do that, I guess.
Okay, nice, he didn't grab me.
All right, get dodged.
Okay, there you go.
Get parried!
Oh shit, oh shit.
Okay, that is impossible.
Okay.
That shit is fucking impal- That's right.
Fuck you.
Boom!
That's right, get fisted!
Bam!
That's right!
Dude, I know you feel pain!
Ooh, oh, your son.
Sorry, I do bitch number one and bitch number two.
worry about your statue tear you preachy old stiff that's
right i know you can feel pain if you're not fighting oh
you're not fighting what okay okay nice okay it's fine i
still managed to dodge that bro he's just tanking it he He's
actually a little tank.
Jesus Christ.
I have the time.
Oh, no.
He actually grabbed me.
Oh, fuck.
I did not expect that.
Bro, okay.
This shit is bullshit.
I'm just going to slap him with this and then grab that.
Oh my god.
What the fuck is this timing?
I'll grab this too.
And then slap you with this as well.
Fuck it.
If I just keep grabbing.
Was it luck?
Oh, no.
Yo, your sons were like stupid, okay?
Your sons were weak as hell.
They were spoiled.
You know, they were only gods because of nepotism.
You're a destroyer like me.
All right, what?
I mashed it!
I say when we're done oh my god oh my god it's scripted it's
fucking I fucking knew it I don't my god it's scripted
oh god are you serious I got beat it's so hard okay that I
just don't I there's no I'll just do this.
Okay, now I know that.
Okay, there you go.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
What?
I'm so bad at dodging this.
Oh, I will admit I'm not very good at dodging those moves.
Like, I could dodge the grabs.
Those are very predictable but oh my god okay but the other
ones are so hard to tag like that oh i keep doing it too
early i keep doing it way too early and it fucking pisses me
off okay that's fine i got him a chokehold
it's okay Bro,
he's so good with the hammer.
Bro, he's so good with the hammer.
You put him last, even in death.
The fuck you say?
Suck you say it, mommy?
Oh, we got a model father here.
That's...
His generational trauma, to be fair.
His dad was bringing fucking shit towards him.
But, don't matter.
How does he get full HP?
And then...
Okay, that's not fair.
I still can't time that shit.
Okay, I timed that, though.
Okay, I needed...
Okay.
What?
Stupid fucking...
Okay, I timed it.
Oh, my God.
And then he fucking does it.
Okay.
Let's fight.
See, I got that correct.
I'm out.
Bro, give me a sec.
There you go.
All right.
That's fine.
That's just cutscene.
That's just cutscene damage.
Oh, nice.
Clever, girl.
Oh, not clever enough.
Okay.
Jesus.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, God.
I got the HP in time.
Nice.
Okay.
Like, see, I got that.
I got that down.
There we go.
Alright, it's fine.
There's no red under him, so it should be fine.
Nope.
No, every time, every fucking time.
Okay, I got that.
I got that though
Okay, nice nice get buried get buried God pay attention to
quick time events.
I see why my sons fell to you.
Oh now you see What I would say this is better not my son
guns and your boy all father has plans for him don't ever
speak about my boy again get out of here i am not lesser
there he is
there's the god of war he's right consider your blood debt
paid that's it Oh, that's a...
That truly was a dad fight.
A title drop.
Oh my god, hey there's... Oh my god, they're here.
Oh my god, they're here.
I'll go get a gateway raid.
Oh my god, my free upgrades!
Yeah!
Get upgrade now!
Okay, that's not what I want to see.
Okay, last appearance.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I can change the appearance.
Wait, I got...
I bought the DLC!
Where is my...
Where's my...
Wait, where is it?
I know I bought the DLC, so where's the cooler axe?
Where is it?
Where's my cool axe?
You must check on Atreus.
I bought the deluxe edition.
Oh, when I can...
Yeah, pay to win a plucky course, guys.
I didn't pay $80 to not win.
It was also literally the only version you can get.
Like, the one on Steam is literally like, oh, would you want
deluxe version?
Or, like, the luxe version plus the art books and the music?
version it was like do you want deluxe version or do you
want pay more and also get an art book yeah deluxe or deluxe
plus thank you there's no standard edition on fucking steam
all right there we go
oh that's so yeah oh wait but i'm covering up my nipple oh
wait this already covers my nipples Yeah, but the less skin
I show, the weaker I am.
I'm not as cool.
I learned that in women's armor.
Oh, I can edit appearance.
Oh, yeah, I want to edit the appearance.
Wait, where is it?
Oh, wait, R2.
I think this is the coolest one.
Oh, wait.
one this one yeah there you go we have better waist armor oh
there it is oh wrist armor oh shit the chains go hard though
I will say the chains do go hard okay the waist oh yeah
there we go wait what I thought I edited the appearance why
the fuck am I covering up my nipples hello um oh wait there
we go oh i have to do it right here there we go nice now it
goes hard gotta have the chains gotta have it without
freedom nipple hey one last thing is where i store all my
power if you got ace here at your door then i reckon your
protection stays busted once you chase odin off you got
another place to lay your head tonight yeah no i hate
delayed attacks repair like where Dodgers.
Because the Dodgers have to be, like, more tight.
Uh-oh.
There we go.
Go through the portal.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Old and surprised.
I'll be like, how about that prick's face when he saw the up
lightning thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
oh is he home knock knock daddy's home had a little dad
fight but i showed him see your dad is stronger than his dad
you know like those fights you're like i've been like that
can beat up your dad and he was right he was right i was
about to look for you i am stronger than the other dad are
you
does he want to uh pay for the roof and what he invited me
to asgard oh i couldn't hear once he went outside i i told
him no obviously he's like sorry about the roof
we're going to asgard but we will bridge
was looking for him you would have said not to so you hid
the truth for me dare you how dare you start a side quest
without me i really did but you're not ready no there's
something you should see no just trust me you'll want to
trust you have broken my trust then let me regain it let me
show you what i found besides we haven't seen the last of
odin And clearly they can just walk in and blast holes in
our home whenever they want.
I mean, that's pretty true.
You can literally just TP in like instant transmission here.
I think I know how.
Sir.
Even if he is right, we don't acknowledge it.
Zoe.
Never apologize.
That's the father's way.
Oh, I got my blades.
Nice.
primary and pure stats like defense to help create a survive
and strength to do more damage equip gear before heading out
all right all right oh wait i got more gear oh shit wait i
got more okay i
feel like this is pretty even now i'll go with this i'm fine
with this
oh the leviathan axe let's see
Oh, shit.
Look at all my knobs.
I'm gonna grab that.
Hold to cause a frost.
Oh, nice.
Any additional rewards?
Cool down.
Oh, okay.
Oh, what do I get for blades of chaos?
I might as well.
Okay, I think all of that is good.
I guess do you have a better boat?
Nope.
Don't care about my son, I guess.
Like, got all my equipment.
Anyway, take this shitty-ass bow that you've had since
birth.
That's, like, crazy.
I'm, like, fucking gearing up for war.
And I'm just, like, and, like, just keep using that wood
bow.
I had so many choices.
where are we going the old temple in the wild woods it's
like it's okay you have magic
well oh wait oh it's just cosmetic all right that doesn't
matter if this is just cosmetic boy like it doesn't matter
to you what the fuck he is oh there is there's the lord okay
i need to know cares for our artists our our treatise Loki
cares for the animals deeply And it's not, okay, yeah, sure
What about the fucking bears?
It's a fucking lie.
You pick and choose.
That's a goddamn lies.
You can't say that you care for all animals deeply When it's
not all animals.
Also, can I...
to do this now oh i can nice okay address me uh
hold to charge up causing spin and slash through okay let's
do while evading hold for an r124 all right let's try let's
get this let's try this out and then oh we'll try this too
Yeah.
You know what?
I think he might be a little racist towards bears.
I don't know.
Just a feeling.
Oh, he does.
I used a sorry boy.
I used up all the XP for myself.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, that must have been this move.
He's averted Ragnarok his own way.
oh xp is separate okay that's good to know i thought it was
being like super greedy what's he up to as i he's like
please dad i'm so hungry and i'm like boy i'll feed you when
i want to feed you arrows something else is out here oh who
else is here boy you will get you can't die boy you don't
need upgrades oh i thought i could like drop it and then
like take your up and fresh did they all get in while the
state was down that yeah boys don't go to the scraps
together you can't even die calm down chat oh oh god about
that what is better the axe or the blades oh yes the bridge
gave out gonna need another path to the temple Why would you
come out this way alone lot?
I had dreams.
How do you use both?
Hey, try using your blades to pull this down.
Okay, it's rage.
Okay Whoa, that one's still alive.
No, look closer Oh hell raiders now who's doing this?
Suppose it's too much to hope that an enemy of theirs should
be a friend of ours Yeah, probably.
Can I chop him down?
Alright.
Alright, nice.
We'd be stringing up raiders like that.
Which way?
Which way, boy?
Okay, that's a broken bridge.
But do I want to?
What's over down here?
Oh, that is free stuff.
I was gonna say.
There must be something over there.
Leave no raider behind.
What's that?
Oh, shit!
What the hell, brother?
What was that?
Yeah, what the fuck was that?
And dangerous.
Be on guard.
Oh, yeah.
Being all the way on guard.
She disappeared.
The free stuff here, though?
Oh, yeah, free stuff.
Here's the temple now.
Just need to find a way around.
Is that...
Oh, wait, no, that's not...
Oh, wait, that is heals.
I actually needed it anyway.
Wait, that's the temple?
But what's over there?
There was a crazy lady back there.
Oh, I'll burn this.
Burn!
Burn, baby, burn.
Okay, nice.
Free stuff.
it wants fast all right go this way boy said this way so I
shall go whoa oh oh they're still alive okay all right
they're still alive oh my god I forgot the boy can also
shoot arrows at him oh shit oh that's what they would mean
by behind I was like behind where do you mean behind behind
when did this bridge collapse oh not a little
i remember to click the other button i said there was
someone i got multitask better about the giants and loki you
mean to the old god of war in these lands who was dead well
for a dead man who didn't seem pretty keen on seeing he
wasn't found right so he might not be dead plus who could be
faking it so enough I knew it.
I was just always hidden stuff back here.
Is there anything?
Nice.
More money.
Come on, boy.
Go in.
Okay.
Burn!
I fucking run!
Get out of here.
Oh, shit.
Wait, you came back.
That's gonna sit.
Is there any back?
It's okay.
I could do this again.
That's right.
And again!
Use it often.
I didn't think I need to use it here.
They weren't that much of a threat.
Like...
They were not a threat to me.
That's like, bro, you're not even, I don't even need to use
my, oh.
Uh, that pillar wasn't in the way last time I came.
An angle, lashed the blade.
Lashed the blade.
Oh.
Am I not latching it?
Oh, it's circle.
Guys, I don't know.
Oh, I can.
Push it back and forth.
That's funny.
I keep thinking it's not a circle because it's not red.
I don't know why, but Brie just can't compute it.
Here was an ally to the giant.
So he'd be on our side if we find him.
She's forgetting that.
I was like, what cheap is that?
Simple is it?
There's a piece out there.
We gotta find him.
How can we not?
Those are many ifs, Atreus.
know you'll see soon is there not supposed to go up there
the shapes what do they mean
it's okay i figured it out i figured out the shapes guys
there you
r2 wait oh there it is
all right nice i fixed it see i'm such a dad i already fixed
it can't imagine what the lies found but he says he has
evidence we've come this far let's see it wait there's
something over there how do i get there
oh not that there's something over there i mean there must
be a cave or some shit right We should keep moving.
Oh.
Charge up with fire.
Follow up with...
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Wait, that's so fucking strong.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, this move is so fucking strong.
I can just do that all the time.
Okay, I need to even shoot your arrows, boy.
Bro, the guy is in front of you, boy.
Oh my god.
okay maybe i should start raging now now there's a bit too
many that's right slam dunk that's fucking right slam dunk
the dunk is your head
again okay don't worry i'm getting over there are you
fucking kidding me i was fucking mashing bro i was so busy
trying to fucking him oh my god that's stupid fucking fire
well i need you to fucking do something real quick for me oh
no boy i said it oh my god why did he grab the health there
boy i oh my god boy you had one instruction it's okay i
still have oh my god you fucking stupid idiot all right
there you go and i'm gonna rage bam that's right set them a
flame or they'll just keep coming all right oh okay i don't
feel pain when i'm angry oh shit okay that was bad timing
it's like or don't feel pain until i do You feel pain!
Okay.
We can grab my health real fast.
All right, nice.
Oh my god, not the fire, not the fire.
Bam!
Okay.
Where is she?
It's fine.
I assume... I assume he's got this right now.
You know what?
Nope.
Okay, I guess they're...
Okay, not enough... Okay, now that's enough range.
I got it.
I was like, whoop, not in enough range, I guess.
Alright, we should be full HP now.
Oh, I grab the blades.
Burn, baby.
Is that everything?
Anything I'm missing?
Nah, we're good.
Isn't it nice how Fimblewinter wore down all the helpful
magic we acquired?
Yet somehow new terrors only flourish.
I know, it's so...
Like, like this.
You know what?
Like...
Oh, shit!
Oh, yeah, this doesn't work.
I forgot there are ice.
My axe is ice.
Sorry, I almost forgot about that important detail.
It's crazy.
Ice is non-effective against ice.
Who would have thought?
What's this?
Read, boy.
Oh, I can read now.
I can read!
Oh, my God.
My boy taught me how to read.
Oh,
yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I don't have to piggyback him anymore.
Oh, my God.
He's growing up.
That's it.
Boy is growing up.
Yeah, it's another boy is growing up.
Yeah, I killed him.
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Easy.
What is this?
Oh yeah, it was this and then...
What's this?
Okay, so this is for climbing.
Let's see if there's anything...
Okay, I just want to make sure there's nothing I'm missing
around.
Oh wait, what's this?
I don't know.
It looked like a thing.
I could chop.
I looked like a chop chop.
I guess I climb up.
Oh, oh!
What?
Oh, wait, that's not her.
That's someone else.
The Huntress?
Oh, my God.
Okay, it wasn't Freya.
Okay.
Oh, wait, I can punch her.
Equality, bitch!
It's self-defense now!
Yeah, that's not Freya.
I thought it was Freya because of the...
Because, you know, she fucking shot.
me it's like a fucking fair assumption when you get shot
from the lady that's been trying to kill me the entire time
bro he's just fucking running fucking coward it's hard to
grow it might be a weak point wait what if oh shit okay i
just have to run how is my axe against here oh my god
Let's keep shooting her!
Shoot her, boy!
Okay.
Oh my god, I keep forgetting she's a fucking deer.
Or a horse.
I don't know.
No, that's a deer.
That's a deer.
Never stand behind a horse, guys.
It's very dangerous.
Oh my god, I did it.
That's it.
I'm going to...
Boy, you go...
Okay, boy.
No, not like that.
Wrong way, boy.
Okay, it's fine.
You need to go.
Jesus Christ.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here!
Self-defense!
Oh hey, nice.
What is she?
Broken my shield.
She broke my shield.
It doesn't matter.
She broke my shield?
It doesn't matter if I got some scraps.
Oh man, at least I got some scraps.
Well, I'm around the to run up and strike.
Oh, okay, new thing.
Oh, nice.
I can put stuff now.
Oh, yeah!
Okay, what about my blade?
Nope.
My shield doesn't regen?
Did I hold it out and want to perform?
Okay.
Oh.
Well, it's like, where's my shield?
It doesn't grow back.
Father, your shield mom gave you.
Thor damaged it.
But now...
No!
Perhaps.
The only thing I have for my wife.
I'm younger than our son.
But like, you know...
That's different.
Why are we here, Treyus?
Okay.
You remember all those shrines we found telling the stories
of giants?
How the panel on the left would be their origin and the
panel on the right would be their fate?
Yes, we found many.
I have seen them.
Well, there's more to them than we realized.
Nothing here?
What the fuck did it bring me here?
Oh, and my huge axe too.
Yeah, it's true.
Yeah, but it's like, um...
It's like a two-for-one deal, you know?
Like, it's matching.
Now I don't have a matching scent no more.
That's different.
Okay, I have to get rid of that tree first.
Can I just chop it here?
Okay, yeah.
That should help.
There we go.
Come on.
Anything else here?
Things collapsing on a regular basis in these parts.
Fimble Winter wears down all things.
There's like so many items here.
Like, I can't reach it.
My legs aren't tall enough.
Oh, there we go.
Yay!
Don't need no legs to get that.
How do I open this, though?
Maybe?
No, that's where I...
Can I open this?
Oh.
Oh, hey.
Just a secret passage.
Nice.
Yeah.
Free robbing time.
Alright, now we can go, boy.
can progress i found the secret tunnel it's plot progression
time all
right oh reading
read boy i only know i only can read in the kindergarten
level
wait he destroyed it oh saruna thank you for the red thank
you thank you yeah we had a great shroom
See, I'm so accepting of my son.
He revealed himself to be a magic user and I accepted him.
Yeah, I don't think he's waiting.
Look, I've, like, I, like, accepted him.
I was like, my son will never be a magic user.
And now I am proud of him.
Somewhere only giants were meant to see.
These shrines tell their stories to the world.
the secret stories we're still working on the furry part one
at a time one at a time Odin captured them because he thinks
it'll help him control when Ragnarok starts I remember but
that's not the whole story see this shows the giant setting
skull and how do you free they're free oh is this the past
or the future depends when you're looking at it spoken like
a giant see The wolves are safe.
Somewhere in Vanaheim.
Okay, so we have to find the wolves.
Oh, my God.
No, is that the horse?
No.
Look, the moon gets stolen.
Uh?
Somehow.
Atreus.
See?
Hathi's got nothing to chase.
And they say celestial theft is a victimless crime.
Who was carrying the moon?
That looked like a horse.
But someone comes along and...
rescues the moon and then the moon blocks out the Sun a
total eclipse oh I haven't seen one of those in a hundred
winters but then they chase an arrow and things go back to
normal what does any of this have to do we're coming to that
look here's Ragnarok do you see who's leading the armies
against Odin that's Tyr if he's to be around at ragnarok
yeah i'm gonna say live yeah because ragnarok hasn't started
yet we're here can this be odin told me he killed tier and
he trusted me at the time or so i thought oh so he was lying
what if he's just had him locked up somewhere all this time
we are back to ifs enough wait we are going home wait i have
one more thing to show you it's just out here
Oh, I can move.
Where is it?
Okay.
Upshot thickens.
Why wouldn't he just kill Tyr to make sure the prophecy
doesn't come true?
Is he stupid?
Well, almost everything.
Yes.
Oh, he went in!
Look at him.
Oh, no.
Other shrines?
How many have you visited?
I...
Well...
This is why you haven't been trading, boy!
All the ones I could still get to in Midgard anyway.
I don't know what it is.
But it's important.
Just like all this.
When I was inside one of the shrines, I saw an image of Tear
imprisoned.
But I couldn't tell where.
There are hints inside the other shrines.
They mention black smoke and the bleeding earth.
but we can never figure out exactly we who's we yeah me me
and helping me Sindri look I talked him into it it it wasn't
his idea Sindri I just needed someone to watch my back bro
you're a fucking rat son you're a fucking rat son what
happened bro you snitched him out just like that could could
the prison be in Musbleheim unlikely Odin's got no presence
I did not raise no rat primordial realms for the bleeding
out sounds like a mine I you got that from your mother good
bet their minds did burst black smoke and Odin's had his
thumb on the dwarves for a very long time that's it then
tears and fartle find somewhere imprisoned in a mine so what
now
Oh shit.
We still have to survive.
This way.
Vlad, even if we can send out looking for Tia.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my shield.
My broken shield.
No!
My wife's gift for me!
But boy, she died.
Alright, I didn't even grab a...
Wait, what's this?
Oh, I can't.
Oh, I can slice multiple.
That's good.
I'm like, oh, fuck.
I need to remember to upgrade for chaos.
Because that doesn't...
Yeah, I need to remember to not waste it for chaos shit.
Jesus, you take so long to level up.
How do you have us getting to Sparklefine?
You know Odin's had all travel between realms locked up
tight.
Sindri said he had an idea or two about that.
Sindri is full of ideas.
Hmm.
The ground looks kind of cracked there.
There's a shortcut this way.
Where?
Oh, this way.
What's under there, Ethan?
Boom!
Ah, back to smashing through things for fun and profit.
That's fucking right.
It's how we do it here.
I'm the god of war, not god of pussy.
Move me here.
they stepped outside but he told us about it I wouldn't
worry what about the things he did not tell us where do we
go from here was that just for loot oh I guess it was just
for loot that does sound pretty cool though my wife is dead
remember when we fought our first troll out this way I
remember you lost control we must tread carefully brother
danger is close you okay fighting without a shield it is not
my first no
okay that's cool
i don't need no shield for what i'm about to do Later!
On the way!
Okay, it's fine.
Well, not fine for my blood, but it's fine for me, though.
It's fine.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
That's fine for me.
There we go.
Chop time.
Chop, chop!
Oh shit!
Wait, I should have just used his weapon.
Bro, his weapon was cool!
That Insta snapped his neck.
Almost home.
Brother, a word.
Yes.
Don't hold the lad's curiosity against him.
It goes with being young.
Yeah, I'll go put a cat in there.
And is that what you wish for him?
Brother, he's going to walk his way.
own path.
If you don't want him walking away from you, then smarten up
and walk with him a while.
Yeah, we don't want to lose him.
We can't leave him unsupervised.
If we could find a way to open Rome travel to Sparta Farm, I
bet there'd be all sorts of useful equipment for us to do.
We will go.
Really?
You could not.
Oh, no, he worked.
You will abandon your search.
Go good.
Just for fun.
Oh, no.
He's already learned to successfully manipulate me.
It's too late.
He used gear.
Sentry.
As I live and breathe.
Is that Atreus?
It's been so long.
How you've grown.
Uh, oh, yeah.
Well, if you'll follow me, I believe he runs.
I believe your favorite dwarves can help you out with that.
We're still your favorite dwarves.
I think he's the only dwarves.
I was like, I think he's only met you guys.
Well, it's like I wrote this game.
After you, my friends.
Almost like I wrote it.
The cleanest cabin in all the nine realms.
And I'd prefer it to stay that way.
not looking at anyone in particular yeah that run was pretty
fucking funny we thought we should make up some rooms until
you can figure out your next moves nearly there so far
this guy's never ran in this life oh that's nice I mean you
won't get any customers other than me but that's nice really
can't beat the view if you're into shimmering gray voids
Like, who's going to fucking find this place other than me?
You have a plan to talk to you about, actually.
Intriguing.
Come in.
Now, if you would just wipe your feet very thoroughly, I'll
wait.
You're not going to wipe your feet, are you?
Okay, then.
Your bedrooms are there.
The kitchen is just over there.
Anybody need a snack?
Kratos?
I'm so hungry.
I do not need a snack.
Oh, okay.
I'm not hungry, I guess.
to Sparta farm so we can try and rescue tier to tier this is
nice i mean that's what it's okay i told him everything
everything you waited my son and disobeyed right i i kept an
eye on him on your behalf nothing risky everything very safe
somebody else speak what's important right okay i have the
other dwarf travel between realms again you said you know a
way yes i do i just It's just, there's, it's just a lot of
mud.
Then why haven't you opened the way already, man?
Well, to be frank, there was something we needed your help
with.
Oh, the Holder brothers finally require the services of the
smartest man alive.
Oh!
Not so fast.
Do we ever find out why he's blue and he's not?
When the hell is he?
Boy, that is my son.
Well, what in all yarns me the happen to him?
What the fuck?
He looks the same.
He's just taller.
And he looks like...
That.
He looks the same.
Well, come on, then.
He's just a little taller.
He's just getting older, you dark plat.
Didn't you ever have an awkward face in your youth?
Hey.
You suppose what he's done is done?
They'll be putting your foot down from now on if you know
what's good.
His dad, their dad's fell in love with a smurf.
All right, let's gear you fuckers up before you go.
I fix my shield, please.
Wouldn't you rather I just whip you up a new one?
No.
It is important to me.
It matches my axe.
see what i can do in the meanwhile how about i fix you up
with something to get you by i guess oh okay i guess i'll
grab something mediocre for high risk and high rewards parry
a shield for absorbing attacks and striking back you know
what fuck it let's gamble
I might miss a lot but it's all about the one time I get it
right and everyone in my chat would be like oh my god donkey
that was so cool it doesn't matter if I fail a million times
but the one time I get it right you're all gonna freak the
fuck out and I'm here for that one high
fuck that was so cool it might take a long time to get it to
happen but when it had the payoff will be worth it i'm here
for the payoff if the kid's gonna insist on getting taller
best make a habit of swinging in for new all right i guess
you can grab something yeah she buried that yeah
50 hits just for that one Perry.
I'd be like, did you see that, guys?
Did I be like fucking bleeding out of, like, bleeding
everywhere?
I'm like, guys, did you see that?
Because I did it.
Because I fucking did it, guys.
Wait, I should grab this, actually.
Upgrade it.
Actually...
Bounce some items you left behind.
Tossed him in the chest.
We will clap for you.
Patch your ass in.
Thank you for the secret chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Things I forgot to loot.
It's going to look so cool, guys, when it happens.
Yeah, I want to...
Okay, that does look good, though.
All right.
Let's do it.
Okay, well, dude.
I like the idea that it's 11 and 17.
Oh, but then it gives me a second rune.
But...
But then 17 looks so cool.
I'm 17 looks so cool.
I'm grabbing that.
Where's the armor I made you?
I used it.
There we go.
I busted my shapely hunkers, forging every manner of
breastplate and paltron in all of creation.
yet now you stand before me two-step from butt ass naked
maybe this go around use it a little more carefully huh i
will not that's right full strength all
right okay wait but we have to change our clothes like can i
upgrade my axe actually i forgot to upgrade my axe Periods,
maw.
Oh, I can.
Alright, let's upgrade.
Oh, shit.
I should have upgraded that too.
Whoops.
It's alright.
I'll do that later.
Need something special?
I need anything else?
Alright, we're good.
Oh, shit.
Let me make sure we got Frida Nippa.
What the fuck?
Oh wait, not you.
Not you.
We got it.
Where is it?
There we go.
It's been freed now.
Oh wait, wait.
He had the door.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
How's life been treating everyone's favorite as your
vulgarian?
The fuck you call me?
Exquisite.
Alright, where do we go?
That's nice.
Definitely made a home here.
It's like, I am not hungry.
I guess this is where they store the food.
Nice to have options if I wake up hungry.
Oh, that's cool.
They have their own little pantry and everything.
Finding everything all right, I hope.
I actually need to pee.
I'll be right back, guys.
Wait, I'm going to grab water and...
I'll go pee and grab water.
That's the order.
I'll be right back, guys.
About water.
All right.
Oh, hello, everyone.
I'm back.
I grabbed my water.
Alan, John, Meddy, Malafelian, X-Factor, Bite, Juge, Mike.
W, Papa, Rice, Solid, Alan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it, guys.
All right, here we go.
This, we have knots.
Oh, my God.
I...
Okay, that's fine.
This is a modern gaming.
I don't have to work.
We have auto save.
We'll just need something from back at the workshop.
Follow me and be sure to bring the head.
See?
Yes, head.
He's imprisoned in a mine somewhere.
He's like, no head?
The realm is full of mines.
You realize you'll need help narrowing your way.
I was like, oh my god, did not save once.
You should talk to Dirling.
is a modern game they have a lot of safety you don't have to
be paranoid works for the city on safety issues should have
access to all kinds of information on mines and i know he's
no friend of odin that's why your mother sought his help
when she was trying to whip up a rebellion ready oh no yeah
oh that's why he blew his mother was a smurf sounds like
exactly what we need i think you missed the ta-da i knew it
his mother was a smurf never mind I'll have this oiled up in
no time meet you at the gateway outside Rebel leader Dirling
If that ain't given a hound a haircut huh and you you just
remember things.
That's why he's blue and he don't you I suppose you think
Dirling just counting the days until a couple of strays show
up looking for trouble What do you mean bro?
Will you help us?
I'm not.
Yeah, no never mind Brock's place to cast disparagations on
my relations this smudge sponge or not withstanding ignoring
you go dark in Durland's door brotherly things for yourself
how it goes just be warned he's not the friendly sort of
dwarf folk you're used to he's cranky as all get out and he
talk money too sounds like a true study in contrast I've
always wanted to see your home realm.
Yeah.
It sounds unique.
Spartal time.
Stupid ace year name.
We look like dark elves to you.
Whoa!
No matter where we go, dwarf elf racisms will always exist.
It ain't hardly somewhere a self-respecting dwarf would show
us.
Tell us old as time.
Let's go, oh, we go outside.
God damn, right.
No matter where we go, no matter what game we play, one
thing we know for sure.
Dwarves and elves is like, just like oil and water.
Through the touching.
Oh, this would be the part requiring your assistance then.
You said it.
This device here has been crafted to your measurements.
It'll help me get a better look at the problem with those.
Oh my god.
We gave him like a wheelchair What the fuck this thing
somehow then.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, this is just to hold you in
place while we shine this light in your eyes Oh shit.
What the fuck stop him somebody stop him
He's professor X now, you know, it fucking sucks apparently
now from the leaks um, he's He's not even going to be on a
wheelchair in Marvel Rivals.
It makes me so sad.
I wanted to run people over.
Yeah.
They're going to be because like apparently he's been like
they cured him or some shit in the comics and like he's been
like he's been like walk like he doesn't he has been like
not on his wheelchair longer than being in the wheelchair.
Permanent damage.
I'll show you.
Permanent damage, are we?
Fuck.
Gritos.
Romy that to him.
Horns first.
You know, cowards.
Someone break his ankles again.
Someone sent another bullet to his spine.
The Bifrost is broken.
Now that we reconciled to these gateways, but it fucking
sucks.
How dare he able to be able to walk again?
I also used it for light.
Okay, good note.
I'll figure something out.
But first, come on, let me show you how it works.
Alright.
How does it work?
Okay.
Is that Swartle Fim?
Oh my god, there's so many worlds.
Oh my god, this is why it takes 25 hours average to beat
this game.
How many worlds are there?
I just noticed all the fucking portals.
this should take you to the wetlands outside need of a lear
city just make your way to the town square and ask for
durlan at the tavern you sure they'll know him at the tavern
durlan's always been in a like congratulations joke you just
finished a tutorial wait you're still in the tutorial it's
like kingdom hearts too you're gonna be the tutorial forever
Roxas hostile slimy foul-smelling creatures but good luck
thanks wait what I said good luck What?
Whoa.
Do you feel that?
Oh, it's sunny now.
It's warm.
Yeah, no more snow.
We can probably use his boat.
If I can just get it free.
Careful, lad.
Oh, my God.
We can fish.
Wait, where the fuck?
How did you already get in combat?
Oh, they're just fucking...
They're just salamanders.
You're getting your ass beat by fucking reptiles.
Oh shit.
I'm getting my ass beat by fucking reptiles Oh my god, don't
make me rage.
Oh My god, so hard to hit the ground.
They're like fucking cockroaches
There you go There's still more
Jesus I'm just gonna switch slap by these guys
another one oh get out of here okay now they're dead talk
smack get smacked oh my god oh my god we can head through
these channels when you're ready
oh my god that reminded me because we're talking about
roaches I started watching the newest season of fallout it's
not bad I can see why people who are like fallout purists
who are like super into like the lore of fallout be mad
about it because um they like changed some stuff about the
lore but like the one thing i don't like about the new
fallout season two is that there's so many plot lives going
on that they keep jumping jumping jumping jumping jumping
jumping and i'm just like i'm like i keep thinking like
that's the end of the episode but they keep jumping to a
next plot point and everything and it's i hate it if you
never ask because i just at least one to two one one one
main story and then another side story but there's like
seven side stories going on at the same time and that's what
the only that's my biggest gripe about it your mother was
far better at fishing than i what's that did you got fish
what the fuck did you get oh yeah you got fish okay which
way do you go left or right are you serious i always looked
Brad, the thing is super chat.
They can think, yeah.
Yeah, in the comics, they, like, made him, like, he's, he's,
like, recovered now.
They healed his legs.
But now he's also, okay, you shouldn't look up to Professor
X anymore.
Unless you're talking about, like, sir, unless you're
talking about the movie version of Professor X, because the
comic book of Professor X is, like, an actual asshole, and
he's apparently, like, really evil.
Like, like, he turned into, like, a super evil guy.
In the comics.
I don't remember what he, like, exactly.
But, like, ever since he learned how to walk.
He's, like, he's, like, a mean person now.
He's like, now that I can walk, I'm better than all of you.
Yeah.
Did you see that over there?
That's what happens when you learn to walk.
You just become evil.
Oh, I grab money.
You learn to walk, but at what cost?
Oh yeah, Magneto is a good guy now, and then yeah.
That's why people were like not happy, no, like, um, when
they're like, when they're like, no!
Why does he know how to walk now?
it we should be able to get through so these are wetlands
huh pretty accurate it is a bog the smell is making my eyes
burn you know what is a fair bit more potent than when I
last visited now that you mention it Larry's like the path
oh they're like geysers oh if only we were in Midgard that
water is frozen in the second there's a puzzle But I know
how to do this.
I freeze the...
Oh, never mind.
I thought I did.
What if you used your axe on it?
I did.
Oh, like that.
Yeah.
Oh, the base!
Oh!
That makes more sense.
That actually does make more sense.
I thought I looked so cool doing that
Alright one Where's the second one Oh Two
Two out of three That has to be around here
Bam Bam Where's the third one?
No, I'm...
All my brain cells is like working overtime, trying to keep
me like breathing.
So I can know how to breathe.
Where the fuck?
Is it like here?
Hidden there?
Where the fuck is...
Oh, it is.
It is.
Tricky.
Clever girl.
Grave Mars Brassard.
Father of a few dwarves.
You may be well familiar with.
Rock may be interested in getting these back.
It's better in his hands than out in the open.
Oh, look in that book.
Oh, I get more XP.
It's from the first game.
Yay, IP.
I think that's dirty enough to go on.
That should be fine.
Yeah, those dwarves know how to build.
I got the app.
I wonder if he and mom ever met.
If he was a part of the rebellion here.
It's certainly possible.
It's so beautiful.
This game.
It's really pretty.
I don't recall if you ever declared allegiance outright.
Come on.
There's gotta be a faster way to get down there.
Yeah, use your fucking app.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I'm...
Maybe not.
Jesus.
Get out of here!
Oh my god, he's fucking god.
You know, fuck it, I might as well.
Snap dunk!
That's right, your head's a basketball now.
Boom!
Is that it?
Alright, no longer, Angie.
L1, Elasperian attack and supply stuff.
I mean, that's what I've been doing.
Oh shit, wait, there's more.
I don't know what the fuck okay bro that's like get out of
here boom that's right haven't felt this cold enough wow
have you that's right get over here has
ice power they've never even seen snow before Boom.
They were like, what is this cold sensation I'm feeling
right now?
Oh my god.
Okay, guys, guys, guys.
Where's my clap?
Guys, guys, guys, start clapping.
Guys, guys, start clapping.
I told you it looked so cool when I do it, right?
I told you the payoff was worth it, guys.
i told you when it happens you guys didn't believe wait
she's actually coded you guys didn't believe get buried was
that it
look at that guys i told you i could do it it would look so
cool when it happened happens.
There's got to be some way to turn the wheel up here.
Well, there.
Give a man some warning if he's about to suddenly end up
snout deep in cheek.
The ground.
Was that an earthquake?
Hmm.
Oh, no.
I guess like, you know, with all the mining here, the land.
Yeah, I was going to say, might be very smart.
I think you can reach the wheel from here.
Or is here?
Boy, don't test me a fucking course I can.
Now, what do I do, boy?
Oh, wow.
Nice job getting it to lower.
Oh, I have to go down.
Yeah.
Maybe it's not that the cold hasn't made it here yet, but
maybe it's just different in Spartofon?
By a lot.
Femble Winter doesn't strike all rare.
Oh, so it'll happen later.
Weird that Femble Winter doesn't always...
make it winter it's like global warming the effects here
appear far more gaseous in nature observe the geysers
observe the aforementioned aroma these effects were present
before in some form but now there's new extremity to them uh
sport ball they give a super chat they can thank you ask
them to say in your intro if you ever go to college station
texas just finished by yelling if i ever have to say that is
that offensive thank you for the super chat support but
thank you thank you i'm worried if i is that offensive in
texas banana thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you if anything x-men is notorious for having the best
comics ever and the most trash runs ever um everyone the
original grouping have flip-flop between good and evil and
morally gray have a nice day thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you i mean i feel like that's most comic
because like like that's most like superhero comics like
it's like so many different writers and they're all just
they have a dartboard and they're just checking things at
the dartboard to see what hits like it doesn't matter it's
like no single person can like you know keep up the
characters i
think we can fit under that bridge all right duck your head
boy that's right This is a strong-ass current.
Where's my snake?
Where's my pet snake?
Where are you at?
Hey, it's blue.
Grab it, boy.
Do your job.
Oh, nice.
Permanent increases by two.
That's nice.
That's more than one.
Alright, I gotta park the boat.
Alright, nice.
parked Oh god, not the fucking stupid salad manners Okay,
it's okay.
I can okay.
I cannot I'm gonna be like See I was like I was gonna be
like I could definitely hit them with my axe Okay, I knew
there's something in here.
Oh shit
Hit that chair up out of here.
That's fucking red.
Boom!
Patreus said, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope I remember all these controls when I play this again.
When we're 2 part 2.
I hope to God I remember all of these controls, guys.
Because it's a lot of controls.
Speed of Morley Gray.
Remember that time Batman had files for every Justice League
member in case they went evil and it was so shocking oh he
has that for every oh it's like it's like a permanent record
type deal but instead of like you know his record is just
how to kill the students
be fair you have a school filled with superpowered like
teenagers going through like puberty and shit like I'd be
worried too I I'm not gonna lie like you know since he is
like the headmaster of like um a squad yeah at your fairy
who can blame him who can fucking blame him
a teenager with no superpowers is already a problem
how do I get up there
uh well I guess I just leave that bucket up there
Oh Guess we Row away Wait look up Gamers don't look up
Gamers never look up You're telling me to do something crazy
right now I'm looking
Is there another up That I'm missing Okay Oh, this?
Fire?
Okay.
Oh, nice.
It's fire.
If all I have spells, it's fire time.
Yeah!
Fire always works.
Alright, now we row away.
I assume it's... Oh wait, there's something glowing in
the... in this lake.
Boy, pick it up, boy.
What is causing this water to glow?
Take it!
Steal their resources, their natural resources, boy.
Bring it back to Midgard.
Oh hey.
Nah, he's dead.
The goddamn salamanders.
I need to use...
Oh my!
The stupid fucking...
Bro, I fucking... I hate...
Okay, there's no such thing as overkill for these guys.
That's it!
There's no such thing as overkill for the fucking style of
manners.
Like, I'm gonna punch the reptile right now.
They deserve it.
What's that?
Did they cap those guys?
Oh.
Hmm.
I think we need to get that wheel moving.
But the water doesn't reach.
The water wheel moving.
Okay.
Alright, but I want to know what's up here first.
Puzzle time.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Guys, guys, guys.
Not yet.
Oh, my God.
Okay, of course they went back down.
It's okay, you didn't look right?
Let's thank God you guys closed your eyes, right?
Where's the other guy?
There he is.
Alright, nice.
Wait, so where do I go?
I didn't even need to, like, freeze it, because there's the
other way here.
What?
Where would this?
Oh, I have to freeze this.
There we go.
Puzzle!
Oh my god, I have to go this way.
War of an ingenuity for you.
Back to the boat.
Boat time.
If the dwarves of this realm are anything like rock and
sundry, it's hard to imagine them siding with Odin.
Well, all too often people are blinded to all but their
immediate self-interest.
Odin offered them safety and defying him can be quite
dangerous.
Maybe they just need a couple of gods to come along and take
the fight to him.
That is not why we are here.
I was only joking.
War is not a joke.
Especially where gods are concerned.
But we're literally, you're literally god of war.
What's the whole point?
My dad is literally the god of war.
And war is not an option?
Might as well not be the god of war anyway.
Like, what's the point of that?
What's the point?
What's the point of having a dad who's the god of war but
doesn't even practice war?
He's the god of not war.
He's retired, Toki.
Let the man rest.
But there was a frog here.
Arteus, get that frog.
Yikes.
This place is wrecked.
And yes, I am staying alert.
There are probably tons of those grim around.
Oh my god, there's like...
Oh, I hear them.
Oh my god, there's so much to explore.
I'm like so...
Everywhere right now, be like, where do I go?
There's so many places to go.
damn
that's fucking right you'll shoot your goddamn arrow boy
I don't need it I have immunity wait I did not have immunity
wait a minute are you trying wait do I not get immunity when
I do the when I fucking Do like the fucking thing?
Do I finish it?
Oh, hey, there's a tree.
Bam!
It's to send a message.
I was like, wait a minute.
I lost HP.
That ain't right.
It's okay.
I'm going to grab a tree for real now.
That's...
Oh my god.
It's okay.
He can't swim, right?
Yeah, no.
What do you mean there's no eye frames?
Oh, shit.
Wait, he can dodge.
I can't dodge my flag shit.
Can't dodge this, though.
What?
What is this doing?
Oh, oh, okay.
Is that the right one?
That's an N.
Okay, that should be the right one.
Yeah, there we go.
We got one of them.
I think it was an R, right?
No.
B or N?
Okay, B.
We're just missing one more.
Oh my god, we gotta explore.
Calling Kratos God a war while the Greek pantheon is dead.
It's like still calling someone the head manager to a
blockbuster employee.
They give us a super chat banana.
They can think it's all he has.
Alright, I'll All right, I'll grab this too.
Please, let him have this.
Nice.
Oh, I had a...
Got attachment.
Let's go.
Look, I know that they're dead.
Look, they're all dead, but I still want to use it.
Oh, it's this.
Oh, yay!
More rage.
That's good.
Daddy has more anger problems.
Yay!
Anger issues.
Let's go, son.
I have no outlet, so I'm going to take it out on these
people.
Good thing you learned the runes, brother.
Yeah, good thing I'm worried!
I'm worried!
Oh, I guess not.
It's like, oh, check it out.
And I was like, what did I learn?
There's nothing inside that head.
I guess that's nothing, I guess.
I guess that's everything there.
Want to get going?
I learned to read not right.
Oh, yeah, it was one step at a time, guys.
step out of time.
I unfortunately did not learn how to fucking write.
Was this just loot?
Oh, I guess loot and achievement.
Bruh.
Mesa, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh,
wait.
There's a fish here.
Loki, grab that fish.
Grab it.
Wait, where did it go?
Wait.
What?
The fish is gone.
Oh, there it is.
Loki, grab it.
Fish.
Oh, my God.
It's gone again.
What's the point, son?
Boy.
Boy, you had one job.
Down I go.
My boy.
Why did you not catch the fish, boy?
I feel
like we're gonna miss a lot of things here.
It seems Atreus, you intend to recruit here as an ally for
war.
I just... I'm trying to keep our options open.
Let's just keep moving.
I'm glad we're out here.
Exploring a new realm.
Maybe we could just try to enjoy the war.
No more snow.
I mean, hey, that's good.
We don't have to deal with snow.
i don't know if i like this room we gotta find a way to open
that gate if we want to get to neither of them i think it's
because i have to row a boat i hate the i hate rowing boats
all right go it's too fast then how should we catch it yeah
flank it attack from behind attack from behind
oh like here oh
Wait, I'll freeze it.
BAM!
There we go.
What is that?
Okay, I don't know.
Oh, it's... Oh, it's loot!
Yeah!
Loot!
Loot, loot, loot.
It was the last of the species, but I got loot, though.
Father, up there.
I'm well.
Oh, up there!
Is it with that?
No.
Oh, I guess I have to get like a prompt or some shit.
There's like an endangered species and I fucking like killed
it for loot.
Because it was an exotic animal.
Halfway there.
There's gotta be another chain to lower the rest of the
gate.
Is there?
Oh, there is.
Wait, what's over here?
Okay, I have to go this way.
I'm not... my legs aren't strong enough.
My thighs aren't strong enough for this.
Whoa!
Oh shit, he's too fast.
It's okay.
Can't dodge this!
That's right!
Bam!
Chop chop!
Good hit, brother.
Wait, there's one more.
There we go.
Juggling time.
Easy.
Yeah, I don't have the thunder thighs to make that jump.
You can tell I worked more on my arms than my legs.
I think you can uncover that geyser from here.
Yep.
Easy.
Alright, that should boost it up.
Oh, wait, no, I do it here.
And then we fix it.
Oh, I think I get it.
If you freeze the geyser, the pressure will turn the wheel.
Yes, boy.
Yes.
Good job, boy.
You understand now.
Oh, okay.
understand okay so i have to time it
look there's a chain we can pull up there
how give me a sec do i should i understand though i
understand though but give me a sec Do you know?
I understand though.
Wait,
Watch this.
There's still the other chain to pull, but how are we gonna
get to it?
I still don't see how we can get up to that chain.
It's wish.
Shoot, let me uh...
Let me cook, boy.
Let me cook!
Oh!
I understand, though.
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
There we go!
Look at that!
I told you I told you I understand I told you I just don't
look up okay that's my only problem I just need to start
looking up yeah as I just have to start looking up and then
everything will go well you should collect any others you
What the fuck?
Fucking pull the chain.
Oh, I guess spamming it.
I keep thinking like if I press...
I was like, smashed Otis, the troll.
I keep thinking that for some reason.
If I may, what exactly are you hoping to learn from Tia?
Well, like I said, I was hoping he could tell me something
about Loki.
Yeah, who the fuck is Loki?
Traveling to other lands.
Yeah, he's supposed to save the world.
Where the fuck is he?
Back in the day.
Just for the history, obviously.
Let's hope Tears in a talkative mood after being imprisoned
for so long.
Not all of Odin's captives can be as charmingly voluble as
myself.
We have no proof Tears truly here.
Right.
I mean, this is a nice vacation spot if he is here.
That earthquake earlier.
Better than the snow.
It's unlikely, but geological disturbances tend to be
unpredictable.
If the geysers and...
There's so many campsites and where are the campers?
Or worse because of fumble winter.
Maybe the earthquakes are too?
Aye.
You might be on to something, lad.
Oh, so... Yeah, it is like global warming.
So they're getting more earthquakes instead of snow.
Oh, they're the campers.
Truly, they're friendly.
Hello!
Friendly?
Are you friendly?
Hey!
Don't point at them.
That's rude.
They're running away.
Yeah, why are they running away?
Hello!
Are you friendly?
I'm just a tourist.
Just a humble tourist.
Why would that for us though?
Oh, why did I just run away?
Is it because I'm tall?
Stay alert.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, they stayed through the alarm.
Bro, I'm just on a fucking boat.
You do not need an alarm for this, guys.
Look at my dingy-ass boat.
Like, how is this a threat to anyone?
Have they never seen a tall person before?
Are they that?
Is it like...
Hey, could we talk to you for...
Are they like...
Oh.
Are they just like trapped in this world and never travel to
different worlds?
Come on, friendly.
Wait, there's a raven.
Where are you?
Hello, little people.
I am very friendly.
I hear Odin's ravens.
The detail in the woodwork is quite extraordinary.
Oh, there must be like a magic, specific magic thing for
this.
That's why it's green.
Oh, hey.
Oh, wait, you have money in the pot.
I fucking knew it.
Sell the rules.
What does that mean?
Yeah.
What can I kill?
Yes, I can.
Is that a statue of Odin?
Oh, shit.
We love him here.
Oh, for you.
It's okay.
We won't tell them who we are.
Yeah.
Or is this a bad time to tell you guys I have not eaten
anything at all?
I just woke up and went straight to stream.
Now I see the chicken and I'm like, me hungry.
Let's see, I did have a little snack.
When I went to get water.
Wait, is Sindri is here?
What the fuck?
Oh, it's because I'm busy collecting all...
Oh, I have a shopping list.
Okay.
I need a barrel of bro.
Okay, I'm not fucking shopping for you Bro, I am not I'm not
your fucking like Uber Eats order
What is it?
What is this injury?
What is a dwarf?
Whoa Oh bird flu fuss.
Thank you.
I appreciate it Oh, if these cobblestones could talk.
Oh my god, there's a lot of green rocks.
Then they'd have mouths.
Uber loot.
Filthy, disgusting mouths.
Do you mind if I fiddle with your bow?
What?
That bow is, like, not special at all.
You are long overdue for our replacement.
Taking advantage of certain material...
Ow.
structural sensitivity to sonic vibrations has been
something I've been meaning to try for quite some time now
thanks for finally trying it what's it gonna be this time
yeah patience I find it's best to see these things oh in
action ah
whoo oh there there's the power of green now take aim at
that gate there but before you loose say ski alpha ski alpha
with the power of green
oh oh shit how was i supposed to know they were there okay
that's fine it's fine I'll be angry.
It's fine.
Snap dunk that fucking salamander.
Whoa!
It's not overkill.
I'm so mad.
Okay, it's fine.
Okay, so, Darylyn.
All right, let's go upgrade our blades, actually.
Any idea where the tavern is?
Oh.
I don't think we need one.
Filthy tavern.
The sewer you just punched the hole through seems promising,
though.
Oh, I don't have a chaos for them.
It's not like you're able to open other doors around here.
I might as well upgrade this for now.
Does it work?
Oh, I should have asked you guys if it's worth fucking
upgrading.
Mara King, thank you again for this super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
This realm is so firm.
Any outsider is considered a threat.
Sounds like an organism if I ever had one.
Uh, silently beaming food into your brain until you order
food.
hot dog with mustard hamburger oh i want hot pot so bad i've
been at hot pot in a while uh crap dinner poutine beef and
broccoli all back stop now i'm so hungry thank you for the
super chat patrick has to thank you thank you thank you
again oh now i'm so hungry it's working i don't know i know
like i can archer this All right, shoot that.
Now it's time to rob them.
That's why they're scared of the tall ones.
That's why I'm justifying their prejudice against tall
people.
Literally came over here to rob them.
How hungry.
All right, let's see.
We go this way.
Oh, wait.
shoot that bird wait that bird's invincible but he's green
but the crow is green best of luck any outsider is
considered a threat is that to protect the dwarfs it sounds
like wait do I have the power of green or going back your
motive wait I thought like I have to hit like he's green so
I have to hit him of green.
Alright, that's right.
You thought that's right.
Get baited.
There we go.
I started the favor.
Alright, I'm gonna ask that bird a little question.
There can only be one bird.
Bird Royale.
Well, everyone's hiding on this side, too.
Odin's occupation of this realm has its hooks in deep.
Left or right?
I'll go.
Oh, right.
Why hide?
Resist and you made an example of.
To keep the rest in line.
Self-preservation can outweigh bravery for even the
strongest of folk.
Fear keeps them safe and alive.
Yeah, it's a bird eat bird world.
Maybe we can try knocking on some doors for directions.
I don't think they're gonna answer.
Aim at the ore and then sonic arrow.
Oh, these?
Oh!
But we're looking for...
Nothing for you here.
I don't care what you want.
No food.
No encouraging word.
No nothing.
Damn.
That's fucking right.
That's what you deserve.
Talking to them.
Is there anything extra here?
I always feel like when I see this, there's like a hidden
item somewhere.
It's like, why?
else would these be here wait
that's something okay not i guess that's not something
oh my god we're like we're like like this door-to-door
salesman
he's like hello hello
I don't know.
It's a book of America a long, long time ago.
Hello.
It's like a house.
If he's here, maybe you should let me do the talking.
Oh, should not have taken that.
We don't want to intimidate him.
As you accepted Kratos as your dad and savior?
Hello.
None taken.
All right, talk to him.
Knock, knock.
I think that's him.
Is that the tavern?
Oh, he's not scared of me.
hello why are you not scared I'm taller than you apparently
there are intruders about I oh really who could it be us I
think yeah well if you're planning on killing me at least
let me finish this song that alarm wasn't just the perfect
key we're just looking for a friend of ours named Dirlin
well we both know that's not true Dirlin's got no friends
left Whoa!
If that's all you need, head out the back way there.
And you'll see the safety office just across the river.
That's fucked up.
What did he do?
Just don't go making trouble for the rest of us.
And while you travel through this realm, maybe you could
clean up the head's mess.
What mess?
Later, brother.
What?
What did he do?
I wish to hear of this.
Yeah.
The rig's in the bay.
Why don't you ask the condescending skull?
Head.
I've got skin.
But he's right.
I made a mistake.
I'd have us shut them down.
In service of Asgard.
What did you do, bro?
You're just ahead.
Shut down the mining rigs?
I don't want to do that.
Oh, is that the Games Composer?
Oh, that's cool.
That's a neat little cameo.
Wait, does that mean, like, it's this way for the mining
stuff?
Or it's before he was just ahead.
I was like, what the fuck?
How did you do all that?
How did you set up a mining operation?
You're just ahead.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, would you like to learn more about my Lord and
Savior, Tokey Bear?
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Here, please be careful.
it's beautiful oh it is beautiful isn't it yeah it's also
very useful you'll be able to find anything your heart
desires with it really as long as your heart desires of
locations your father and you decide and plot to travel
together ah it's my tracker it is my yellow pain but a
beautiful compass now scamper off all right okay
oh my god oh my god okay who's that's me that's the shop oh
are these the oil what is that oh what the fuck okay we'll
go i guess we'll go
we'll go there all right uh get me out of here hello i'm
pressing circle
Excuse me?
I swear to God, guys.
I am absolutely pressing circle.
I swear to God.
Hello?
Oh, my God.
It requires me to do a tutorial.
Oh, that's why.
Okay, that makes sense.
I was like, why am I...
Why is it preventing me?
Oh, my God.
I finally have the golden...
I finally have a compass.
A boat cannot be far.
Huh.
Really, your Sindhu made it sound like Darlene was some sort
of rebellion leader.
Doesn't sound like anyone's following him.
Was being the key word to your little brother.
Yeah, he has no friends now.
He's just some crazy guy.
And no one wants to listen to.
Yeah.
Let's set this up.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I'm still there.
Oh!
where I'm currently locked, okay?
But at least I have fast travel now.
Oh my gosh, more boats.
Alright, I think this is a good time to stop.
I'm feeling more boat travel.
Wait, actually, is there...
Will I be here?
I don't want to roll my boat right now.
I also don't want to overdo it because I am sick, so I want
to give myself more time.
Time to recover.
But it's been fun so far.
I've been enjoying...
I've been enjoying the gameplay and the story so far.
It's really, really, really about gently down the stream.
So I really don't want to overdo it.
Really don't want to overdo the stream.
Because I am still sick.
And I want to have time to recover.
And also grab food.
But thank you all for watching Part 1 of God of War.
I hope I remember my controls.
But also, like...
Okay.
I want to know, like, would it take me here?
I hope it doesn't, like, go take me all the way back to the
beginning.
I don't know where the auto saves are, technically, for
this.
I'm very confused where it's saving me.
So I hope it takes me here.
I hope I'll be here when I come back.
So we'll see you.
we'll see how it goes uh but great start to god of war i did
save it i just saved it don't worry guys i'll save it again
just to be more paranoid uh but i hope you guys enjoyed part
one of god of war uh ragnarok i'm enjoying the playthrough
so far i hope i remember all the controls by next
playthrough uh we are gonna do like two per week as well
because it is a very long game And if I feel like if I do a
one per week, I'm definitely not going to remember the
controls.
What else?
I hope the volume was okay.
I will look back just to be sure.
But if the volume needs adjusting, just let me know.
Was the volume okay for the playthrough?
Or should I adjust it more?
No good?
All right, good.
That's good.
No need to adjust.
Anyway, guys.
hope you guys have a good good day rest of your day today
i'm gonna get some food um yeah because i'm i'm hungry um
and i didn't get today so i'm gonna grab some food and then
relax a little bit get some work done uh and hope i recover
fast because tomorrow we have uh i believe tomorrow is is
tomorrow saturday i've lost track of days ever since i got
sick like days definitely blur together for me oh yeah
tomorrow is oh my god today is friday but tomorrow is such a
today.
Uh, but anyway, uh, tomorrow we have Metal Gear Solid with
Mint.
Um, I don't know if we're doing it like every week or we're
just like, like, um, every other week yet because like I
said, since there's two of us, we do have to like, uh, align
our schedules for it.
But, but we do have Metal Gear Solid next week.
So, I'm not next week, this week.
Um, no, no plans yet, but whether or not we're having it
next week as well.
But we're finally having Little Nightmares Part 2 a
chibi-doki next week we're going back we're going it's
coming back i know there was a long gap in between but both
of us got very busy so and i was also very burnt out with
collabs as well so we're bringing it back part two for
little nightmares um but yeah like i said like we both got
really busy and i was like super burnt out as well during
the last year the last couple of months but we're finally
bring it back.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up
and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stayed up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.